YOU EVERYBODY AND WELCOME TO
THE ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
JOINT COMMITTEE HEARING A DUE
TO OUR CONTINUED STAY AT HOME
ORDER WERE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING SO WE'RE ONLY ALLOWING
A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
THIS ROOM- PARTICIPATING IN
PERSON MOST OF THEM WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRING THAT MASS BE
WARNED AND PHYSICALLY PHYSICAL
DISTANCING MAY BE MAINTAINED BY
ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM WARRANTED THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. AND IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A MASK WE WILL
PROVIDE ONE. TO YOU. AND
BECAUSE- LET'S SEE. SO WE HAVE
A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION FOR ANYONE
WHO'S WATCHING OR LISTENING.
FOR THE PUBLIC THAT'S IN THE
ROOM. WHEN WE REACH THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PORTION OF THE AGENDA
I'M GOING TO ASK THAT ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE ROOM APPROACH THE MIKE ONLY
ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
MAINTAINING APPROPRIATE SOCIAL
DISTANCING AS YOU MOVE AROUND
THE ROOM. AND I WILL ASK THAT
YOU NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU'RE DONE PROVIDING YOUR
COMMENTS OR YOU CAN RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT. AND AS YOU'RE
LEAVING THE CAPITAL ALSO PLEASE
MAINTAIN SOCIAL DISTANCING ARE
ONLY ALLOWING ONE PERSON IN THE
ELEVATOR AT A TIME. FOR THOSE
WHO ARE- VIDEO CONFERENCING WHO
ARE AT OUR VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOM OR REMOTE TESTIFYING
STATIONS FOR THE WITNESSES- WE-
LET'S SEE. YOU WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN SO WE'LL BE ABLE TO
SEE YOU IF YOUR VIDEO
TESTIFYING IF YOU ARE ON THE
TELEPHONE WE WILL HEAR YOU WILL
TAKE TESTIMONY FROM ALL THE
WITNESSES ON EACH PANEL- AND
THEN WE WILL ASK QUESTIONS AT
THE END OF EACH PANEL SO FOR
THE WITNESSES IF YOU COULD
STAND BY SO THAT WE CAN ASK ME
QUESTIONS OR LET US KNOW IN
ADVANCE IF YOU CAN'T. WAIT TO
TELL THEM. AND THEN FOR DIAL IN
WITNESSES. WE'RE GOING TO BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR YOU AND FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN THAT'S. 877-692-8950
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
420-213-1542 ZERO TWO THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBERON THE ASSEMBLY WEBSITE
AND ON YOUR SCREEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING US. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE TO PROVIDER
PUBLIC COMMENT. IF YOU'RE
CALLING AND YOU HAVE TO
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
YOU MUTE THE LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART DEVICE
OTHERWISE IT WILL ECHO AND WILL
WILL HAVE TO DISCONNECT YOU.
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO NEED TO
LIMIT HOW LONG EACH PERSON HAS
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. AS
WE NEED TO EXIT THE HEARING
ROOM IN TIME FOR CLEANING UP
PRIOR TO THE NEXT HEARING. SO
CALL IN A TESTIMONY AND IN
PERSON TESTIMONY WILL BE
LIMITED TO TWO MINUTES APIECE.
SO WITH THAT SAID LET'S TURN TO
THE HEARING. NOW WE ALL ARE
AWARE OF PLASTIC POLLUTION IN
CALIFORNIA THIS IS REALLY
CAPTURED THE PUBLIC'S ATTENTION
THOSE OF US WITH CHILDREN KNOW
THAT THEY ARE BEING TAUGHT
ABOUT PLASTIC POLLUTION IN
SCHOOL WE'VE ALL SEEN I HOPE
WE'VE ALL SEEN THE REALLY SAD
AND SHOCKING VIDEOS OF THE
IMPACT OF PLASTIC POLLUTION ON
WILDLIFE. WITH BOTH BIRDS AND
MARINE WILDLIFE I'M DYING
BECAUSE OF THE PLASTIC
POLLUTION WHICH IS NOW COMING
CLOSE TO OVERTAKING THE AMOUNT
OF FISH THAT ARE IN THE OCEAN.
I ANYBODY WHO DIES OR SWIM SEES
THE AMOUNT OF PLASTIC POLLUTION
WHICH SOMETIMES IS INVISIBLE
BECAUSE IT'S HARD TO SEE IN THE
WATER BUT IT'S THERE AND IT
WASHES P ON SHORE AND IT'S
REALLY A HORRIBLE THING THAT
WE'RE DOING TO OUR PLANET IN
THAT WE'RE LEAVING OUR CHILDREN
BEHIND- UNFORTUNATELY. THE
MATERIAL THAT SHIPPED INTO OUR
STATE- FROM OUT OF STATE A LOT
OF TIMES- IT REALLY IS LEFT UP
TO OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
DEAL WITH THE IMPACTS BOTH
ENVIRONMENTALLY AND ALSO
FINANCIALLY. LAST MONTH I
ATTENDED A TORN OREGON
WASHINGTON TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THEIR RECYCLING SYSTEMS. AFTER
MEETING WITH EXPERTS IN BOTH
STATES IT'S CLEAR THAT WE SHARE
A LOT OF THE SAME CHALLENGES ON
THE WEST COAST. ARE WE ALL HAVE
NO REAL WAY OF MANAGING THE
PROLIFERATION OF PLASTIC AND
THIS IS A CRISIS THAT'S
AFFECTING EVERYBODY
PARTICULARLY COASTAL STATES.
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS SENATOR
BEN ALLEN ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLYWOMAN LORENA GONZALEZ
ALONG WITH MYSELF AND MANY
OTHER JOINT AUTHORS AND CO
AUTHORS WORKED TO PASS SB FIFTY
FOUR IN AB TEN EIGHTY. BILLS
THAT WOULD HAVE ESTABLISHED THE
CALIFORNIA CIRCULAR ECONOMY AND
PLASTIC POLLUTION REDUCTION
ACT. UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL
DID NOT PASS THE FLOOR AND
PLASTIC CONTINUES TO POSE A
THREAT TO THE ENVIRONMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH WITH NO
SOLUTIONS. ON THE CURRENT
HORIZON. TODAY'S JOINT HEARING
IS INTENDED TO FURTHER OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THESE IMPROVE
THE IMPACTS OF PLASTIC ON THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE REPRESENT.
MOST OF US ARE AWARE AS I SAID
ON THE IMPACT ON MARINE
ENVIRONMENT BUT THE IMPACTS OF
PLASTIC POLLUTION EXTEND TO THE
ERROR WE BLEW IT BRIEFED. THE
WATER WE DRINK THE FOOD WE EAT.
THE CONTENT OF OUR OF OUR BLOOD
AT THIS POINT- HAS BEEN
IMPACTED BY PLASTICS. AS WELL
AS OUR HEALTH AND THESE IMPACTS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT OUR
WHAT'S CALLED OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES THESE ARE
MANY TIMES LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES MANY TIMES
MINORITY. COMMUNITIES AND THEY
BEAR A DISPROPORTIONATE BRUNT
OF THE IMPACTS OF POLLUTION AND
PLASTIC POLLUTION. I'D LIKE TO
THANK MR MCCARTY FIRST
PARTICIPATION AS CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE. AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMITTEE FOR
JOINING US TODAY. MR MCCARTY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE ANY
OPENING STATEMENTS I THINK YOU
JUST OUT BRIEFLY SO CERTAINLY I
AM PLEASED TO BE HERE AS A
MEMBER OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE BUT ALSO AS YOU SAID.
CHAIR THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
WASTE REDUCTION RECYCLING IN
THE ISSUE OF PLASTICS IN OUR
SOCIETY IS ONE THAT WE ALL KNOW
ABOUT FROM FOR MANY ASPECTS- AS
YOU SAID. CERTAINLY IF YOU TALK
TO ANY SCHOOL KID TODAY AND
KIND PROJECT THEY DO IN THEIR
SCIENCE CLASS IT'S USUALLY
ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF. PLASTIC
ON OUR RIVERS AND OCEAN AND
IMPACT ON WILDLIFE BUT THERE
ARE ISSUES TO. OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN OUR CITIES IN
OUR STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
TAXPAYERS AS WELL SO I KNOW
THAT THIS HEARINGS GOING TO BE
FOCUSED ON THE IMPACTS THAT.
THE REALISTIC HEALTH IMPACTS TO
SOCIETY BUT ALSO LOOKING AT THE
MANAGEMENT ISUES. AND AS YOU
SAID- THINGS THAT WE DIDN'T
THINK ABOUT YEARS AGO OUT
PLASTICS NOT JUST IN THE
STREETS IN OUR CREEKS BUT- ENDS
UP IN OUR BLOOD SYSTEM. AND
THESE MICROPLASTICS REALLY HAVE
AN IMPACT ON ON THE ON THE
HUMAN BODY WHICH WE'RE GONNA
TALK ABOUT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUES WELL SUCK LOOK FOR
TODAY'S HEARING NOT JUST THE
THAT REALITY BUT ALSO STEPS
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN DO. TO
MITIGATE THESE ISSUES SO LET'S
BEGIN THANK YOU. THANK YOU O.
M. ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS ON THE
PHONE WHO WANT TO MAKE ANY
OPENING STATEMENTS. OR- VIDEO
CONFERENCING. I KNOW WE HAVE MR
AL MURATSUCHI ON THE PHONE WITH
US. SO I WOULD JUST ASK IF HE
IS INTERESTED TO REACH OUT FOR
THE SERGEANTS. OKAY NOT HEARING
ANY WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO OUR
FIRST PANEL ON THE IMPACTS OF
PLASTIC. THIS ON THIS PANEL
WHICH HAS BEEN JOINED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
DID YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY
OPENINGS. OKAY OUR FIRST PANEL
CONSISTS OF- ANDREA LEON
GROSSMANN WITH THE LOS ANGELES
REMOTE IF WITH- AS ALL- CHELSEA
ROCHMAN PROFESSOR WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF TORONTO AND TERRA
BROKE WITH OCEANIA. HI WE HAVE
OUR FIRST WITNESS PLEASE. FIRST
WITNESS. HELLO I SEE SOMEBODY
THERE WE GO. HI WE CAN SEE YOU
CAN YOU HEAR US I WOULD. OKAY
OKAY YES CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAMP WELCOME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE. OKAY HI MY
NAME IS ANDREA GROSSMAN AND I
AM THE CLIMATE ACTION DIRECTOR
WITH A SCHOOL. TODAY I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU CAN SEE MY POWER
POINT PRESENTATION. LET US LET
US GET FED UP ON THE SCREEN IT
ONE MOMENT IS SET UP ON THE
SCREEN. ONE MOMENT THANK YOU. I
AM VERY SORRY- IF YOU COULD BE
PATIENT WITH US PLEASE WE
SKIPPED OUR FIRST OPENING
WITNESS WE HAVE AN OVERVIEW
FROM ROSS FROM WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO HIM FIRST
AND THEN COME RIGHT BACK TO YOU.
THANKS. HELLO GET READY FOR ME.
YES WE CAN WELCOME OKAY- SO I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROSS BROWN AT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO
JUST PROVIDE THE VERY BRIEF
PRESENTATION TO KICK THINGS OFF
WITH SOME JUST BACKGROUND
INFORMATION TO SET THE STAGE IN
THE CONTEXT FOR THE REST OF THE
HEARING- YOU SHOULD HAVE
RECEIVED HOPEFULLY- HANDOUT
THAT WE PUT TOGETHER THAT'S
TITLED OVERVIEW OF PLASTICS AND
CALIFORNIA- AND I'M JUST GONNA
BE WALKING THROUGH SOME OF THE
INFORMATION THAT'S IN THAT HAND
OUT. FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO MAY NOT HAVE A COPY OF
THAT- THAT HAND OUT IS POSTED
ON OUR WEBSITE IT'S ALEJO DOT
CA DOT GOV AND IT SHOULD BE
POSTED ON THE RIGHT HAND SIDE
OF THAT WEBSITE FOR PEOPLE TO
FOLLOW ALONG. I SO GONNA DIE
RIGHT INTO IT PAGE. OF THE
HANDOUTS. ARE REALLY JUST
SUMMARIZE A SOME OF THE MAJOR
GOALS AND POLICIES OF THE STATE
IS ENACTED- BUT BOTH SORT OF
BROAD- WASTE GOALS AS WELL AS
GOALS ARE SPECIFICALLY RELATED
TO PLASTICS- AS YOU ALL KNOW
THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING PROGRAM FOCUSES ON
ALL. A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
KINDS OF- BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
INCLUDING. PLASTIC CONTAINERS-
THERE'S A STATEWIDE RECYCLING
GOAL WHICH WAS ADOPTED IN
TWENTY ELEVEN. THAT ESTABLISHES
A GOAL OF 75% SOURCE REDUCTION
RECYCLING COMPOSTING BY TWENTY
TWENTY AND I'LL GET BACK TO
THAT IN JUST ONE MOMENT- THE
SINGLE USE PLASTIC BAG BAN
WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED IN LIKE
THIS LEGISLATION AND THEN.
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN- AND I'M I'M NOT
GONNA GO THROUGH ALL OF THESE
JUST TO KIND OF TOUCH ON A FEW
OF THEM IN THE FINAL LINE OF
COURSE- THIS PAST YEAR
MANDATORY RECYCLING CONTENTS
AND PLASTIC BOTTLES. I WHICH
REQUIRES THAT PLASTIC BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS CONSIST OF A MINIMUM
OF. 50% RECYCLED CONTENT BY
TWENTY THIRTY SO THAT'S JUST
KIND OF TO SET THE STAGE A BIT
ON SOME OF THE STATE POLICIES-
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE TWO OTHER
HAND OUT I'M GONNA. JUMP INTO
JUST A FEW DIFFERENT PIECES OF
DATA AND INFORMATION- I KIND OF
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE STATE OF
WISDOM. AND PLASTICS IN
CALIFORNIA VERY HIGH LEVEL SO.
PAGE TWO SHOWS A CHART OF- THIS
IS ANNUAL LANDFILLED WASTE IN
TERMS OF BILLIONS OF TIMES.
OVER THE LAST- TEN OR FIFTEEN
YEARS OR SO AND AS YOU CAN SEE
THAT- THAT AMOUNT WAS
DECREASING UNTIL- SEVERAL YEARS
AGO AND HAS BEEN INCREASING
OVER THE LAST. SEVERAL YEARS
AND I DO WANT TO NOTE THIS IS
NOT JUST PLASTICS THIS S
OVERALL. A LANDFILLED WASTE-
AND THE ESTIMATED RECYCLING
RATE WHICH I MENTIONED BEFORE
WHERE THE STATE HAS A GOAL OF
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT- WAS 40%
ANDTWENTY EIGHTEEN SO JUST TO
GIVE YOU A- A SENSE OF CONTEXT
OF WHERE WE ARE. AND THAT GOAL-
AND SO BEFORE I MOVE ON TO SOME
SOME OF THE REMAINING CHARTS
WHICH FOCUS A LITTLE BIT MORE
SPECIFICALLY. ON PLASTICS I DO
WANT TO NOTE THAT. AS REPORTING
THE PRESENTE TOGETHER WITH THAT
KIND OF REALIZED THAT YOU KNOW
THROUGH CONVERSATIONS WITH
DEPARTMENT THAT'S- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THERE'S NOT. GREAT
OF FULLER. OF ALL OF THE
PLASTIC THAT COMES INTO THE
STATE ON EXACTLY WHERE ALL
THAT. PLASTIC ENDS UP WHETHER
IT BE LANDFILLS OR WHETHER IT'S
EXPORTED- OR RECYCLED
DOMESTICALLY WITHOUT YOUR
PIECES OF INFORMATION ON THAT
WE'RE GONNA. TRY TO HIT ON SOME
OF THOSE KEY PIECES OF
INFORMATION BUT- I'M JUST NOT
KIND OF A FULL ACCOUNTING OF.
ALL THE PLASTIC AND EXACTLY
WHERE IT GOES- IT WAS THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO FIND. SO IF YOU
TURN TO PAGE THREE OF THE
HANDOUT OR SCROLL TO PAGE THREE
OF THE HANDOUT- THIS IS JUST A
PICTURE OF THE KIND OF THE
OVERALL AMOUNTS OF WASTE THAT.
I WENT INTO LANDFILLS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. AND YOU CAN SEE THAT
WEBSITE THAT CHART GIVES YOU
SORT OF THE PROPORTION IT'S
PLASTIC TO ABOUT 12% OF. OVER
ALWAYS THAT WENT INTO LANDFILLS
WAS PLASTIC. THAT'S ABOUT FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION TONS- IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND AS YOU
KNOW THERE'S A THAT THIS
INCLUDES A WIDE VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PLASTIC-
MATERIALS FROM. TWO CONTAINERS
TO TRASH BAGS TO BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS AND SOME CASES. TOYS
AND FURNITURE- AND THEN IN
TERMS OF HOW THIS HAS CHANGED
OVER TIME- THE OVERALL PERCENT
GOING INTO LANDFILLS. HAS GROWN
FROM TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AT NINE
POINT 6% TO ELEVEN POINT 5% TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO THAT IS. HAS
GONE UP OF THE LAST DECADE OR
SO. IF YOU. TO NOW TO PAGE.
FOUR OF THE HAND- THIS IS DUE
JUST A- OF A BIT OF A PICTURE
OF. THE MAIN PLASTIC BOTTLES
THAT ARE SUBJECT TO THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PROGRAM SO THIS IS JUST
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS AND- ONES
THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
STATE'S BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING PROGRAM- THEY RATE OF
RECYCLING OF THOSE CONTAINERS.
AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE CHART
HAS REMAINED. RELATIVELY
STEADY. OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS OVER SEVENTY PERCENT-
HOWEVER I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT-
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS AND
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO THE PROGRAM PLASTIC
ONES. ARE REALLY ONLY MAKE UP A
VERY SMALL SHARE OF THE OVERALL
AMOUNT OF PLASTIC. AND THE
STATE AND THESE ARE THE TYPES
OF- CONTAINERS THAT- ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO BE
RECYCLED- BUT THEY ARE VERY
SMALL SHARE OF KIND OF OVERALL
PLASTIC IN THE STATE. ESTIMATED
ABOUT TWO TO THREE PERCENT. OF
OVERALL PLASTIC- AND THE IN
TERMS OF THE OVERALL VOLUME
AMOUNT OF CONTAINERS- ALTHOUGH
THE RECYCLING RATE AS MAY
REMAIN RELATIVELY STEADY- THE
OVERALL VOLUME HAS INCREASED
SUBSTANTIALLY SINCE TWENTY TEN
SO. FIVE POINT FIVE BILLION- OF
THESE PLASTIC BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS AND TWENTY TEN HAS
GROWN TO. ABOUT NINE POINT TWO
BILLION. OTHERS A MINOR TYPO
AND THEIR RECENT MILLION BUT
IT'S- NINE POINT TWO BILLION.
AND TWENTY NINETEEN JUST TO
GIVE YOU A SENSE FOR- THE SCALE
THERE. AND THEN FINALLY- IF YOU
TURN TO PAGE FIVE OF YOUR- OF
THE HANDOUT OR SCROLL TO PAGE
FIVE- HERE'S SOME INFORMATION
ON- ON PLASTIC EXPORTS. IN
RECENT YEARS- HISTORICALLY MOST
RECYCLABLE PLASTIC HAS BEEN
EXPORTED TO OTHER COUNTRIES-
IT'S THROUGH CITRIX WORKS- AND
AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE CHART
HERE- THERE'S BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT DECLINE IN THE
AMOUNT OF PLASTICS OF RIGHT IT
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PLASTICS
THAT HAVE BEEN EXPORTED- OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS- EXPORT.
OF PLASTIC SAYS DECLINES DUE TO
INCREASED REGULATIONS AND
RESTRICTIONS ON INTERNATIONAL
IMPORTS OF PLASTIC WASTE AS I'M
SURE. MOST OR ALL OF YOUR
FAMILIAR WITH CHINA'S NATIONAL
SWORD POLICY IS ONE OF THE- ONE
EXAMPLE OF THAT I WHICH IS KIND
OF RESTRICTED THE AMOUNT OF
PLASTICS- THAT BUT CAN BE
EXPORTED. AND THERE ARE SOME
THE LAST BUT WE KNOW THERE IS
THERE ARE SOME NEW GLOBAL
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE PLAN TO
BE IMPLEMENTED IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WHICH COULD. EVEN FURTHER
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF PLASTIC.
THAT CAN BE EXPORTED- WITH THE
INTENT OF BEING RECYCLED- SO
GETTING BACK TO KIND OF UR
EARLIER POINT. YOU CAN SEE FROM
THE CHART THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT
THE- AMOUNT OF PLASTICS
EXPORTED HAS DECREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY BUT- WE DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY- AT LEAST ON THE
DATA THAT WE'VE SEEN AS
EXACTLY. WHERE ALL OF THAT
PLASTIC HAS GONE SOME OF THAT
pDOMESTICALLY POTENTIALLY. I
SUMMIT COULD END UP IN
LANDFILLS COULD END UP IN OTHER
PLACES SO THAT'S I THINK ONE OF
THE- AN EXAMPLE OF KIND OF THAT
DATA GAP ON INFORMATION THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A GREAT AND A LOT OF
THIS PLAN IT SEEMS. IS EXACTLY.
WHERE THAT- PLASTIC IT'S GOING.
NOW SO- I WILL IN MY COMMENTS
THERE AND OF COURSE I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER. ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
I WILL FIRST TASK GIVEN OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE- HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. NO I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR. A FOR YOUR
OVERVIEW IT GIVES US A VERY
GOOD- I THINK APPRECIATION FOR
THE SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM AND
ALSO. A CERTAINLY IN THE TREND
THAT WE'RE HAVING IN TERMS OF
PLASTIC POLLUTION AND LANDFILL
IMPACTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY AND NOW WE WILL MOVE TO
OUR FIRST PANEL. SO IF WE COULD
PLEASE HAVE MISS LEON GROSSMANN
BACK. ON THE SCREEN AND- HI
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
YOUR POWER POINT IT. IS ON THE
SCREEN AS WELL SO YOU CAN BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU. SO AGAIN MY NAME IS ANDREA
LEON GROSSMANN- THE CLIMATE
ACTION DIRECTOR WITH US ALL.
I'M HERE TODAY. TO PRESENT A
PLASTIC IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
IMPACT ON OUR COMMUNITIES AND
ENVIRONMENT AND THANK YOU FOR.
HAVING ME TODAY. AT NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. I'M PLASTIC IS AN
INVENTOR ENVIRONMENTAL
INJUSTICE OUR MEMBERS OF THESE
COMMUNITIES HAVE ILLNESSES
RELATED TO AN EXTRACTIVE
ECONOMY INCLUDING ASTRA HIGH
RISK PREGNANCIES AND CANCER. I
TOOK THIS PICTURE A COUPLE
YEARS BACK IN WILMINGTON THEY
HAVE SIX REFINERIES AND IF YOU
CAN SEE MOST OF THESE PEOPLE
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES. NEXT
LIFELESS. OVER HALF A MILLION
PEOPLE LIVE WITHIN A HALF MILE
OFTEN OIL WELL IN L. A. COUNTY.
OTHERS ALSO OVER FIVE THOUSAND
ACTIVE OIL WELLS. AND THIS IS
JUST A SNAPSHOT OF THE COUCH
AND MAP FOR LA AND YOU CAN SEE
ALL THE OIL WELLS THAT WE HAVE.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. THIS IS THE
SAME MAP FOR THE CALIBERS
SCREEN. ONE OF THE ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION CALIFORNIANS
LEAVING WITH- POLLUTION- AROUND
LIVE AROUND HERE IN 92% OF THEM
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR. LIFELIKE
PLEASE. SO THIS IS AN OVERLAY
OF THE OIL EXTRACTION AND THE
CALIBER SCREEN AND YOU CAN SEE
DEFINITELY THE CORRELATION
BETWEEN THE TWO OF THEM.
NEIGHBORHOOD DRILLING IS
ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. SOME GONNA TAKE YOU
THROUGH THE LIFE CYCLE OF
PLASTICS OR LIKE I CALL IT THAT
THAT CYCLE OF CLASSICS SO IT
ALL STARTS WITH EXTRACTION AND
THAT'S WHY I STARTED THE
PRESENTATION THE WAY STARTED.
DRILLING FOR OIL AND GAS
HAPPENS IN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES. LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
ARE EXPLOSIVE TO THE STOCKS THE
COMMISSION SINCE BILL.
INCLUDING PERSONAGENS AND ALL
KINDS OF TOXINS IN THE AIR NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. ONCE WE EXTRACT
THE HYDROCARBONS WE HAVE TO
TRANSPORT TO REFINERIES. AND
OTHER INDUSTRIALIZED AREAS WE
KNOW THAT LIVING NEXT TO
TRANSPORTATION HOBSON CORRIDORS
EXPOSES PEOPLE TO HAVE ELECT
LEVELS OF AIRBORNE POLLUTANTS.
LIKE FIGHT PLEASE. THEN WE HAVE
THE PRODUCTION AND
MANUFACTURING AND AGAIN
REFINERIES AND FACTORIES ARE
REALLY WORKING OUT NEXT TO A
EACH DAY COMMUNITIES. I IN THIS
FACILITY OFTEN ARE NEXT TO
WATERWAYS AND THE POLLUTANTS
AND UP IN THE WATERWAYS AND
THEY GET A CARRY POLLUTION TO
THE OCEAN. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
ONCE THE PLASTICS ALREADY
FACTOR THEY HAVE TO BE
DISTRIBUTED AND WE KNOW THAT
WE'RE HOUSES HAVE INDIRECT
SOURCE EMISSIONS. AND PEOPLE
LIVING NEXT DOOR HOUSES ARE
ALSO LOW INCOME PEOPLE OF
COLOR- BEN WILSON NO THAT THEY
LIVE NEXT TO THE FREEWAY FOR
ALL THESE SINGLE USE BUSES ARE
TRANSPORTED. TO AND FROM NEXT
LIKE PLEASE. THEN CORPORATION
SPEND MARKETING DOLLARS TO
ENSURE MAXIMUM PENETRATION IN
COMMUNITIES. WE KNOW THAT
DOLLAR STORES ARE LOCATED- IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND THEY
BASICALLY PROMOTE THEIR VALUE
BECAUSE OF HOW CHEAP AND
CONVENIENT THEY ARE. AND WE
KNOW ALSO THAT THEY HAVE.
SUBSTANCES LIKE BPA BPF AND
FOLLETT'S. THAT ENDS UP HAVING
A- TOXIC IMPACT IN IN OUR
BODIES ESPECIALLY PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO OTHER
TYPES OF CONTAINERS THAT ARE
REUSABLE- AND AGAIN THEIR
TENDER BASICALLY PROMOTED IN.
AJ COMMUNITIES WE ALSO KNOW
THAT SHE FABRICS ALSO PROMOTING
EAGER COMMUNITIES AND THOSE
MICROPLASTICS END UP IN OUR
WATERWAYS- IN THOSE ARE AND THE
CONGRESS OFFICE AS WELL NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. I'M AND AGAIN
BECAUSE WE'RE USING THESE-
CHEAP. AERIALS THAT JUST
BREAKDOWN FOR FAIRLY EASY WE
KNOW WE HAVE TO HOLD THEM AND
THAT MEANS MORE EXPENSIVE
DRIVING THEM TO LANDFILLS AND
GETTING RID OF THEM- AND THE-
THAT WAYS AND THE CREATING. A
METHANE AND METHANE IS A REALLY
POTENT GAS THAT IS CONTRIBUTING
TO CLIMATE CHANGE NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. SO EVEN IF WE DISCARDED
WASTE PROPERLY WE KNOW THAT
HE'S GOING TO FIND A WAY TO THE
OCEAN AND LAND AND LANDFILLS.
UP AGAIN- WHERE PEOPLE OF COLOR
LIVE. AND THEY'RE GETTING
EXPOSED TO EVEN MORE POLLUTION-
SOME OF THE WAYS AND OF BEING
INCINERATED AND NOW WE KNOW
THAT THEIR ALSO TELLING- WASTE
TO ENERGY- SCHEMES THAT ARE
ALSO OF. HURTING EITHER
COMMUNITIES AND WE NEED TO
REALLY FIND A WAY TO STOP
THESE. THAT CYCLE NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. I'M MORE FULLY FROM
BEGINNING TO THE OCEAN ALSO
MEANS MUCH THAT SOUNDS AN
INCREASE OF SENATORS
ACIDIFICATION LESSON SILVA
FORTUNE OFF CARBON. ON THE
CLIMATE CRISIS IS AFFECTING
EITHER COMMUNITIES
PROPORTIONALLY AND THE PLASTIC
IS CONTRIBUTING TO IT. AB
PREVALENCE OF MICROPLASTICS IN
THE OCEAN WITH OTHER ADVOCATION
FEEL THE BOTTOM OF THE FOOD
CHAIN. AND THAT'S AFFECTING
BIODIVERSITY AND THE FOOD CHAIN
AS A WHOLE MAKEMAKES LIKELY. WE
SIMPLY CANNOT RECYCLE THE WAY
OUT OF THIS PROBLEM. MOST
PROFESSORS ARE NOT RECYCLED AND
THOSE THAT DO RECYCLE ONES
BECAUSE MANY FACTORS PREFER
MATERIALS. AT RECYCLING ALSO
GENERATES GREENHOUSE GASES ARE
YOU NEED MORE ENERGY TO RECYCLE
THOSE PLASTICS. AND RECYCLING
PLANTS AND OF ANY TO
COMMUNITIES- WORLDWIDE 90% OF
PLASTICS ARE ESTIMATED TO BE
RECYCLED 12% ARE INCINERATED.
AND 79% ARE EITHER LANDFILL OR
IN THE IN THE OCEAN. SO WITH
THAT I'M CLOSING MY REMARKS AND
I'M OPENING FOR QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING
TO ASK THE QUESTIONS AT THE END
OF THE PANEL SO IF YOU DON'T
MIND JUST STANDING BY WE
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT MOVING TO CHELSEA
ROCHMAN PROFESSOR WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF TORONTO. WHO I
BELIEVE IS BY PHONE IF THE
MODERATOR COMPLETES CONNECTOR.
AND CAL THE AIRLINE AS THE OPEN.
THANK YOU CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME
I THINK I'M CONNECTED WE CAN
HEAR YOU AND WE ALSO SEE YOUR
POWER POINT. OKAY WONDERFUL I
CAN'T BUT I WILL- SUGGEST WHEN
HIS ADVANCE FLY THAT HOPES WILL
BE OKAY. I JUST WANT TO START
BY BY THINKING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND MCCARTY MCCARTY
FOR INVITING ME TO GATHER TO
GIVE ME SOME TIME I GUESS TO
TALK ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE- MY NAME IS HEALTHY ROCK
MAN I'M A PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF TORONTO. AND BUT
I DID ALL OF MY SCHOOLING IN
CALIFORNIA AND LIVED THERE FOR
QUITE SOME TIME SO IT IT. GREAT
TO BE ABLE TO BE HERE- TODAY
I'M GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
GROWING EMISSIONS OF
MICROPLASTICS MOSTLY FOCUSING
ON THEIR IMPACTS AND TO THESE
ARE THE BIG PLASTIC THAT
EVENTUALLY BREAK DOWN INTO
SMALLER CLASSIC. THAT ARE SO.
IF WE GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE. I
THINK IT'S SAFE TO SAY. SAY
THAT WE ARE AGREE- INTO
FIFTEEN. BUT THE WORLD DECIDED
THAT EIGHT MILLION TONS OF
PLASTIC GOING INTO THE OCEAN
WOULD NOT OKAY THIS WAS A
FAMOUS DETECT THAT WAS SHARED
BY JANET YEAH BACK IN THE PAPER
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN. YOUR THE
NEXT SLIDE WE RECENTLY TRIED TO
UPDATE THIS ARE WE GET UPDATE
THIS MODEL TO COME UP WITH.
MORE AT CURRENT NUMBERS HOW
MUCH PLASTIC DEBRIS WAS BEING
ADMITTED INTO AQUATIC
ECOSYSTEMS. THIS IS WORK DONE
THAT INCLUDED JENNA JAMBECK BUT
WAS LED BY DR AL. CAME OUT IN
SCIENCE IF YOU WEEKS AGO WE
PREDICTED THAT THAT NUMBER HAD
INCREASED THE NINETEEN TO
TWENTY THREE. MILLION TONS OF
PLASTIC BEING ADMITTED INTO
YOUR QUALITY CONSISTENT IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND TODAY IT'S
ABOUT TWENTY FOUR TO THIRTY
FOUR MILLION METRIC TONS. WE
HAVEN'T DECREASED OUR EMISSIONS
AND FACT WE'VE INCREASED OUR
EMISSIONS AND IF YOU GO TO THE
NEXT SLIDE. IF YOU FOLLOW THAT
YELLOW LINE WE PREDICT THAT
UNDER BUSINESS AS USUAL ALL THE
WITH NO MEDICATION AND
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE'RE DOING
TODAY. THAT WILL BE UP TO
ALMOST NINETY MILLION TONNES
ATTENTION ONLY. BY TWENTY
THIRTY WHICH WOULD BE A FOUR
FOLD INCREASE FROM THAT TWENTY
SIXTEEN NUMBER. LUCKILY NO ONE
THE GREED ON THE SCENARIO WHICH
IS WHY WE'RE ALL HERE TODAY. TO
DISCUSS. PLASTIC POLLUTION IN
OUR ENVIRONMENT. IF YOU GO TO
THE NEXT SLIDE. AND PART TODAY
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF HOW. THESE
PLANS AT OUR PARTY KEEP. IN
THEY DO TO MARINE AND FOR. LIFE
SO KNOW THAT. LARGE PIECES OF
PLASTIC LITTER OUR ENVIRONMENT
FROM THE POLE TO THE EQUATOR
AND FROM THE SURFACE OF THE
OCEAN TO THE D. T. WHILE WE
KNOW THAT BYE WEEK MOST OF THIS
MATERIAL IS LARGE PLASTIC. IF
YOU GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE. THE
MAJORITY OF BY COUNTY ARE
MICROPLASTICS. THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY DIVERSE CONTAMINANT
IT INCLUDES MANY DIFFERENT
TYPES OF PLASTIC THAT ARE
BROKEN DOWN FROM A DIVERSE AND-
NUMBER OF PRODUCTS. THEY ALL
HAVE DIFFERENT CHEMICALS IN
THEM THEY RANGE IN DIFFERENT
SIZES FROM THE NANO TO
MICROMETERS RANGE. IN DIFFERENT
SHAPES DIFFERENT COLORS AND
DIFFERENT CHEMICALS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT. AND THE NEXT FLIGHT
SHOWS BUT THEY'RE EVERYWHERE
AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY QUITE
PERVASIVE. YOU WANT A LOT ABOUT
THIS ISSUE OVER THE YEARS. AND
THAT INCLUDES. IF YOU GO TO THE
NEXT SLIDE. THE FACT THAT THE
CONTAMINATION IS REALLY
WIDESPREAD SO I SAID THIS
EARLIER ABOUT LARGE PLASTIC.
MICROPLASTICS ARE OFTEN SEEN IN
EVERY SINGLE ECOSYSTEM. NEXT
SLIDE. WE ALSO SEE THEM AND HOT.
AND SOMETIMES THESE
CONCENTRATIONS ARE QUITE HIGH
NEXT SLIDE. HERE'S AN EXAMPLE
AB Q. ORGANISMS WHERE THE
CONCENTRATION OR THE NUMBER OF
PARTICLES IN THE BODY WAS
ASTOUNDING THE PICTURE ON THE
LEFT IN THE BROWN'S BULL HAD
TAKEN FROM LAKE ONTARIO NEAR
TORONTO WITH NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
PARTICLES IN IT STANEK. AND THE
PICTURE ON THE RIGHT IS THE
SHARK THAT HAD MORE THAN THIRTY
EIGHT HUNDRED PIECES OF
PARTICLES OF MICROPLASTIC IN
ITS STOMACH. NOW THAT HIGH
CONTAMINATION IS NOT JUST
RELEVANT TO AQUATIC ANIMAL IF
YOU GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE YOU
CAN SEE HOW IT'S ALSO RELEVANT
TO HUMAN WE EXTRACT RESOURCES
FROM OUR OCEAN AND FRESH WATER
TO EAT WE ALSO TAKES ALL. ALSO
TO EAT. AND IF YOU'RE NOT BY.
WE'RE ALSO STARTING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT MICROPLASTIC
ISN'T DRINKING WATER. WE KNOW A
LOT MORE ABOUT FRESH WATER
SYSTEMS IN THE CONTAMINATION
THAT THEY HAVE. AND IF FOR
EXAMPLE IF I TURN ON MY CAP
RIGHT HERE AT HOME IN LAKE
ONTARIO THE THREE IMAGES ON THE
BOTTOM ARE WHAT WE SEE UNDER A
MICROSCOPE AND OUR VERY OWN
LAB. SO WE KNOW THAT THEIR
ENVIRONMENT IS CONTAMINATED AND
WE KNOW THAT IT'S COMING BACK
TO HAUNT US ON OUR OWN DINNER
PLATE. SO THAT REALLY WAIT
RAISES QUESTIONS ABOUT NEXT
SLIDE WHAT ARE THE EFFECTS OF
MICROPLASTICS WHAT ARE THE
EFFECTS TO HUMANS AND WHAT ARE
THE AFFECTED ANIMALS. THERE ARE
THREE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES THAT
I PUT THE FACTS INTO THE TO GO
TO THE NEXT SLIDE. BIG INCLUDE
A STATE MOTIVE IN. PLASTIC
UNION JACK. TRANSFERRING TO THE
LIVER OR KIDNEY MAY BE CAUSING
INFLAMMATION. OR PLASTIC BEING
INGESTED IN HIGH CONCENTRATION
CAUSING MORTALITY IN A FISH
BECAUSE THEY ATE SO MUCH
PLASTIC THEY DIDN'T EAT THE
FOOD THAT THEY NEED TO SURVIVE.
YOU GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE. WE
SEE EVIDENCE OF A FAX FROM
CHEMICALS ADDITIVES TO PLASTIC
SO HERE ON THE TOP ARTISTS
EXPOSED TO THE LEACHATE THAT
TIRED THAT THE COMMON MICRO
PLASTIC IN THE ENVIRONMENT. AND
N. B. AND B. WHERE THEY WERE
EXPOSED TO THE LEACHATE THEY'VE
LOCKED THE PIGMENTATION IN
THEIR EYES. THIS IS A CHEMICAL
OF FACT WE ALSO SEE IN WORMS
AND IN FACT FROM THE
MICROPLASTIC WITH ADDITIVES AND
THE ADDITIVE ALONE BUT NOT THE
PLASTIC IF WE REMOVE THE
CHEMICAL ADDITIVE SO EVIDENCE
AGAIN OF A CHEMICAL BACK. AND
THE NEXT SLIDE SHOWS EVIDENCE
OF THE FACT THAT COULD BE FROM
THE CHEMICALS THAT START TO
ACCUMULATE ON THE MICROPLASTICS
WHEN THEY END UP IN THE
ENVIRONMENT. SO THE MINUTE A
PIECE OF MICROPLASTIC HIT DATA
QUITE ECOSYSTEM START TO
ACCUMULATE THE PESTICIDES IN
THE FLAME RETARDANT IN THE
METALS AND THE OTHER CHEMICALS
THAT ARE THERE AND THOSE CAN
ALSO CAUSE INCREASED. AS YOU
SEE ON THE TOP RIGHT OR EVEN
THE TUMOR IN THE LIVER OF A
FISH BUT YOU SEE AT THE BOTTOM
RIGHT AND THESE ARE STUDIES
WE'VE DONE IN MY LAB BOTH AT UC
DAVIS WHEN I WAS AT MY POST DOC
AS WELL AS- IN MY LAB HERE IN
TORONTO. SO THE NEXT FLIGHT GET
THREE. THE ACTUALLY YOU WANT
JUST GO ALL THE WAY TO THE
WHITE YOU CAN THE THREE THINGS.
THERE'S A QUICK IF YOU TO. THIS
SHOW THAT THERE IS AN- YOU
MICHAEL. MAKING THE DIFFERENT
TACK. BUT THEY ALSO IN
ORGANISMS ACROSS THE WELL OF BY.
OR SO THEY CAN CAUSE A TOXIC
EFFECT IN THE BODY BUT THOSE
EFFECTS CAN ALSO LEAD TO A
POPULATION LEVEL ATTRACT.
INCREASING OR DECREASING THE
POPULATION. MORE CHANGING THE
COMMUNITY. SO ON THE NEXT
FLIGHT WHICH SHOULD LOOK LIKE A
I AM A WHITE GRASS WITH LEVELS
OF ORGANIZATION ON THE ON THE
Y. AXIS THROUGHOUT THE LAST AT
THE SIDE OF ON THE BOTTOM. WE
LOOK ACROSS THE LITERATURE CARE
GIPHY HOW MUCH EVIDENCE IS
THERE AN IMPACT FROM PLASTIC.
SO YOU'RE GONNA BE IN A MINUTE
WHAT HOW MUCH EVIDENCE THERE
IS. AND THE DARKER THE SHEETING
THE MORE EVIDENCE THERE IS. AND
YOU'LL SEE THAT THESE BOXES ARE
GOING TO CORRESPOND WITH THE
SIZE OF THE PLASTIC FOR THE
THINK. BIG PLASTIC NOW AND THE
LEVEL OF ORGANIZATION IF YOU GO
TO THE NEXT SLIDE YOU CAN SEE.
HOW MUCH EVIDENCE THERE IS
ABOUT A ONE HALF TO AQUATIC
BIOTA. WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
EVIDENCE FROM MY GRIP THAT
MICROPLASTIC IMPACT ANIMALS
ACROSS MANY LEVELS OF
BIOLOGICAL ORGANISATION.
MORAXELLA IN THOSE LOWER LEVEL
BECAUSE THOSE ARE FROM
LABORATORY EXPERIMENTS. WE
DON'T DOES LARGE ANIMALS WITH
MACRO PLASTICS ON THE RIGHT
SIDE OF THE GRAPH YOU'RE SEEING
ANIMALS THAT WASHED UP WITH.
LACERATIONS ARE PLASTIC IN
THERE GOT TO COST MORTALITY.
THANK YOU ARE THE NEXT FIGHT
YOU CAN SEE HOW THIS EVIDENCE
HAS INCREASED FROM TWENTY
THIRTEEN. TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN
MORE BOXES ARE FILLED AND THE
SCALE OF THE BOXES. HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY. HOWEVER IF YOU
CLICK ON THE NEXT SLIDE. YOU
CAN SEE THAT WE ALL THE ADMIN
THAT SOMETIMES MAKE A PLASTIC
DOES BECAUSE OF THE FACT. IN
SOME. THAT WE CAST IN OREGON
FOR FACT. WE MIGHT NOT GET.
THEY THAT WERE LOOK FOR YEAH
SEE THAT LESS STOCKS WITH MAC
CLASS. BUT THE THREE THE OF. IF
YOU GO TO THE NET IDEA CAN SEE
THE HAVE TO DO IT HOW. CLASS IS
IN THE IN. THE TYPE AND SHAPE
OF PLASTIC BEAR THE ANNA THAT
IT INTERACTS WITH BY THE
PLASTIC OR IN A STUDY HOW THEY
GET THEIR EXPERIMENTAL DESIGN.
BUT THE LAST FRIDAY WHEN I SHOW
YOU BEFORE IRAQ THAT IS THAT WE
KNOW THAT EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE A
LOT OF QUESTIONS TO ASK IF YOU
GO TO THAT NEXT FIGHT WITH THAT
THE GRAPH AND THE PICTURES. THE
WORLD SHOULD BE THERE TO PAPER
THAT DEMONSTRATED THROUGH MODEL
THAT WITH THE EVIDENCE WE
CURRENTLY HAVE THERE'S ALREADY
ENOUGH PLASTIC IN SOME PARTS OF
THE OCEAN. AND SOME PARTS OF
FRESHWATER ECOSYSTEMS BETTER
CAUSING AN IMPACT. WE'RE SEEING
EVIDENCE OF MEASURABLE RISK ARE
READY AND WE EXPECT MORE IF WE
CONTINUE BUSINESS AS USUAL. SO
TO CONCLUDE JEFF CAN'T GO GIVE
IT AN OVERALL SUMMARY WE KNOW
THAT LARGE PLASTIC DEBRIS CAN
HARM WILDLIFE THERE'S NO DOUBT.
FOR MICROPLASTICS THERE'S
EVIDENCE THAT IT CERTAINLY
CAN'T THE WHEN AND HOW WITH A
LITTLE BIT COMPLICATED. BUT WE
KNOW THAT MICROPLASTICS ARE
ALREADY LEADING TO MEASURABLE
RISK IN FRESHWATER AND MARINE
ECOSYSTEM. THE WHILE WE TRY TO
UNDERSTAND MORE ABOUT THE ISSUE
OF MICROPLASTICS WE ALSO SHOULD
START THINKING ABOUT HOW WE CAN
REDUCE. MICROPLASTIC IN BIG
PLASTIC. THE MISSION THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK VERY MUCH
PROFESSOR IF YOU TO MIND BY
WHILE WE TO OUR LAST. IN THEM
OVER TO BACK FOR QUESTION.
THANK YOU ARE LAST S FOR THE
FIRST PANEL IS TERROR BROKE
WITH THE OCEAN WITH OSHANA. AND
MODERATOR WOULD YOU MIND
CONNECTING TERROR BROKE. AT
INTERIOR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU AND I CAN'T SEE MY POWER
POINT BUT- WILL ALSO- TRUCK BUT
IT'S UP AND- HAVE PLAYED THE
DANCE THAT BY WORK THROUGH MY
PRESENTATION YES WE CAN SAY IT
AGAIN LEAVING IS TERRA. OKAY
GREAT- THE VIDEO THE LITTLE THE
LANE SO I APOLOGIZE BUT I'M NOT
ABLE TO BE THERE IN PERSON OR
OR VIA VIDEO- BUT THANK YOU FOR
INVITING US TO PARTICIPATE
TODAY- I WILL TALK A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THE IMPACT ON THE
MARINE ENVIRONMENT YOU'VE
YOU'VE HEARD MUCH OF THAT-
BEFORE- AS THE CHAIR SAID IN
THE BEGINNING MANY FOLKS ARE
NOW VERY FAMILIAR WITH THESE
ISSUES AND- YOU HEARD- FROM
FROM OUR PREVIOUS WITNESSES
WHILE SO HOPEFULLY I CAN MOVE
QUICKLY COULD ACTUALLY. GET GET
THE QUEUE IN A- SO. ONE THING I
ALL LIKE THE ABOUT IN THE WHERE
HAS. THE WE ARE A PLAN AND-
OCEANS COVER MORE. THAT PERCENT
OF OUR OR THIRD FAT. AND ARE
REALLY CRITICAL TO LIFE ON OUR
PLANET BECAUSE THEY PROVIDE 50%
OF THE EARTH OXIGEN. AND
DESPITE THE OCEAN IMPORTANT TO
LIFE ON EARTH. THEY ARE
LITERALLY STARTING TO CHOKE ON
PLASTIC AND AS ONE FINDS THAT
RECENTLY PUT IT. THE OCEANS ARE
PUTTING PLASTIC BACK AT US WITH
EVERYWHERE. SO OUR ENVIRONMENT
AS YOU'VE HEARD HAS BEING
INUNDATED WITH THE MATERIAL
THAT DOESN'T BIODEGRADE IT
BUILDS UP IN OUR ENVIRONMENT
AND THREATENS MARINE ANIMALS AS
WELL AS HUMAN. AND THE
VERSATILITY AND DURABILITY OF
PLASTIC IS WHAT REALLY BECAUSE
IT'S BECOME SO PREVALENT AND
PERSISTENT IN OUR ENVIRONMENT.
AND WHILE WE FOCUS ON OCEAN
PLASTIC HAVE BEEN FOUND AROUND
THE GLOBE IN FRESHWATER LAKES
AND MELTING ARCTIC SEA ICE AND
RAIN COLLECTED IN THE MOUNTAINS
AND IN THE AIR ABOUT THE FRENCH
PEYRONIE'S- SO WE ARE REALLY
SEEING CLASSIC THROUGHOUT OUR-
OUR CLUB. AND I FIGHT THE
ALBATROSS FOR FLORIDA THE-
POSTER CHILD FOR OCEAN PLASTIC
POLLUTION AND THAT'S BECAUSE
THEY TRAVEL THOUSANDS OF MILES
ACROSS THE OCEAN TO FEED AT B.
AND THEIR PREFERRED PREFERRED
SHOULD IT WHAT AND WHICH TEND
TO ATTACH THEMSELVES THE
FLOATING PIECES OF PLASTIC. AND
PLASTIC BOTTLE VERY OFTEN
BRIGHTLY COLORED AND SO AT THE
TRACTOR TO AN ANIMAL FLYING
ABOVE A VERY FAST OCEAN. AN
ADULT ALL THE TRAPS WELL THEN
WHO IS THAT AND FEED THEM TO
THEIR CHECK TO BELIZE WILL PULL
UP THE CLASSIC MAKING THEM FEEL
FALL. EVEN THOUGH THEY LACK ANY
REAL NOURISHMENT AND I'M SURE
MANY OF YOU HAVE SEEN THE
PICTURES OF ALBATROS CHECK-
WITH THEIR BELLY FULL PACKED-
PLASTICS THAT WORK THAT HAS
START TO THAT. BUT ALL THE
TRUCKS ARE FAR FROM THE ONLY
BIRD SPECIES THREATENED BY
PLASTIC. 90% OF THE BIRD
SPECIES HAVE CONSUMED PLASTIC
THE RESULT OF WHICH- CAN BE
FATAL. OUR NEXT BY IT'S- WHEN
EXPERT ON OF THE MATH MARK AND
THEN I. FIFTIES IT WAS REALLY
FELLOW FROM LIFE MARKET. AND
TODAY AS WE KNOW DRINK OUR
COFFEE OUT OF PLASTIC CUPS WITH
THE FACT THAT LIDS AND- STRAWS.
AND OUR PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
AND CLEANING SUPPLIES ARE ALL
PACKED. IT REALLY MAKES OUR
LIFE EASIER AND FOR PRETTY
CHEAP. AND AS YOU AS YOU HEARD
SEVERAL TIMES THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS- PRESENTATIONS AN
ESTIMATED EIGHT MILLION METRIC
TONS ENTERED THE MARINE
ENVIRONMENT LANDAY SOURCES
EVERY YEAR. AND THAT'S
EQUIVALENT TO ABOUT SEVENTEEN
POINT SIX BILLION POUNDS OF
PLASTIC. AND ONCE THEY GET
THERE IT DOESN'T TEND TO GO
AWAY. AND EVERY YEAR THE OCEAN
CONSERVANCY ORGANIZES AN ERROR.
THE WORLD COLLECT AND RECORD
DECLINE ALONG OUR CLOTHES. AND
THE DATA COMPILED INTO AN
ANNUAL REPORT REVEALING THE
MOST COMMONLY COLLECTED ITEMS.
I ONE OF THE BIGGEST OFFENDERS
THAT WE SEE ARE SINGLE USE
PLASTICS PARTICULARLY FOOD
WHERE AND PACKAGING. MOORLACH
BUT LACKS I THINK. AN ESTIMATED
SEVEN HUNDRED WEARING JEANS AND
QUITTING MANY ENDANGERED
SPECIES ARE AFFECTED BY MARINE
PLASTIC POLLUTION EVEN THOUGH
PLANTS AND AS YOU HEARD TINY
MARINE ORGANISMS THAT FORM THE
BASE OF THE OCEAN FOOD CHAIN
ARE EATING PLASTIC WHICH THAN
CAN ACCUMULATE AND LARGER OCEAN
PREDATORS LIKE FISH THAT WE EAT.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE PLASTIC LOOK
LIKE THOSE OF FOR EXAMPLE
PICTURES PLASTIC BACK IN
OCTOBER. ONE OF THE FEATURED
OLD FAVORITE JELLY. AND I
TWENTY STUDY THAT INVESTIGATED
PLASTIC AND A HUNDRED AND TO
SEE A TURTLE FOUND PLASTIC IN
EVERY INDIVIDUAL THAT THEY AND
INVESTIGATED. AND I'M SURE MANY
HAD SEEN THE VIDEO THAT HURDLE
WHAT THAT STRAW LOGINIS KNOWS
THAT WENT VIRAL A COUPLE YEARS
AGO AND RELEASED BIRDS- PUSH
BACK ON THE USE OF. MILLION
PLASTIC STRAWS NATIONWIDE. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. AND EVERYTHING
LOTTERY THEIR CAR REACHED AND
STUDY FOUND CLASS THROUGHOUT
THE WATER COLUMN FROM THE
SURFACE THE PEOPLE AND IN EVERY
ANIMAL THAT THEY SAMPLED AND
THE PHOTOS HERE IS THAT THE
DEEP SEA CRAB HOLDING A PIECE
OF PLASTIC THAT WAS TAKEN BY MY
COLLEAGUE DURING A TWENTY
FOURTEEN EXPEDITION OF THE
SEAMOUNTS INSANE BUT TAKE AWAY
HERE AND IT'S- A CLASSIC A
PERFECT MEMORY IMPAIRMENT AND
IT IS EVERYWHERE NOT QUITE.
THESE AND TWENTY FIFTH THE
LOOKS THING MORE THAN FOUR
MILLION METRIC TONS OF PLASTIC
EVERY YEAR MORE THAN A THIRD OF
WHICH- IT'S FOR PACKAGING.
WHICH IS OFTEN USED ONCE AND
THROWN AWAY. AND PLASTIC
PRODUCTION ISN'T BUYING NOW IN
FACT IT'S GROWING FASTER THE
NETWORK AND BY TWENTY FIFTEEN
WE ARE PROJECTED TO BE PRETTY
THING FOUR TIMES AS MUCH
PLASTIC. AS WE WERE IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN. AND ALMOST ALL
PLASTICS ARE MADE FROM POP
APPEAL WHICH HAVE YOU HEARD
CONTRIBUTE TO CLIMATE CHANGE
FROM EXTRACTION TO PUT
PRODUCTION TO THE VERY END OF
LIFE A PLASTIC. I'M SORRY BUT I
MIGHT HAVE IF THE FLAG SO YOUR
POLICY AYE AND THAT'S LIKELY. I
HOPE YOU ARE SEEING A GRAPH AT
THAT POINT- AND THAT THAT WAS
THE GRAPH I WAS JUST REFERRING
TO ON THE PLASTIC PRODUCTION TO
CLOSE YOUR FILE- QUITE A PLANE
FROM TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
FIFTEEN. AND NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
AND IF YOU CAN QUIT NOW THE
FULL PART AS AN ANIMATION- THAT
WRITERS RECENTLY CREATED
VISUALIZING THE NUMBER OF
PLASTIC BOTTLES BEING SOLD
GLOBALLY- SHOWING THE SIZE OF
THE PILE GROWING OVER TIME TO
REFLECT THE NUMBER OF BOTTLES
BEING PURCHASE. MPK BOTTLED ARE
COMMONLY USED AS WE NOW BURKE
OFFERING SOME WATER BUT CAN
ALSO BE USED IN OTHER HOUSEHOLD
OR PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS AND
DATA SHOWS THAT MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY BILLION OF THESE
BOTTLES WERE SOLD IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ALONG WHICH IS ALMOST
A MILLION EVERY MINUTE. AND IT
FIFTY ONE PERCENT- THEN WHAT
WITH THE OLD AND TWO THOUSAND
NINE. WHAT THAT'S WONDERFUL
MINUTE YOU'LL NOTICE THAT THE
DUMP TRUCK REALLY- IS LONG GONE
AND YOU'RE. LEFT WITH A
MOUNTAIN OF PLASTIC BOTTLES.
I'M NOT QUITE. SO IF YOU LET
THAT PLAY ILLUSTRATIONS REALLY
SHALL THAT WHAT A PILE FACT
THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE IF IT WAS
COLLECTED OVER A LONGER PERIOD
OF TIME THE NUMBER SOLD EVERY
DAY BUT CREATE A PILOT HALF THE
SIZE OF THE EIFFEL TOWER. NEXT
SLIDE. AFTER A MONTH- YOU HAVE
FORTY BILLION BOTTLES WHICH
WOULD REALLY DOOR THE EIFFEL
TOWER. AND BY AND OVER THE PAST
TEN YEARS THANK YOU THOUSAND
NINE YOU HAVE FOUR TRILLION- P.
E. T. BOTTLES SOLD WHICH WENT
OUR ABOUT NEW YORK CITY AT
ABOUT ONE AND A HALF MILE HI.
NECKLINE. SO THAT EIGHT MILLION
METRIC TONS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT GOING INTO THE OCEAN
ANNUALLY THAT IS ABOUT THE
EQUIVALENT OF A DUMP TRUCK LOAD
EVERY MINUTE AND THE
CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATE IS THAT
THIS WILL INCREASE DRAMATICALLY
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND I
THINK WE JUST HEARD WE CAN
UPDATED DATA FROM OUR LAST
PRESENTER THAT WE MIGHT ALREADY
BE HERE AND SO THE AMOUNT OF
PLASTIC IN THE OCEAN IS REALLY
PROJECTED TO SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE- IF WE CONTINUE ON THECURRENT COURSE. AND THE IMPACT
THE MARINE ENVIRONMENT WHILE
THEY COULD REALLY BEAT THE
BACKGROUND. NEXT SLIDE. BUT
THERE IS SOME GOOD NEWS- THE
AMOUNT OF COUNTRYWIDE PLASTIC
LEGISLATION HAS REALLY
INCREASED RAPIDLY IN REPAIRS AS
AWARENESS OF PLASTIC POLLUTION
BECOMES MORE WIDESPREAD- THERE
BEEN POLICIES- PUT FORWARD
AROUND THE WORLD INCLUDING IN
CALIFORNIA- SO THERE IS SOME
GOOD NEWS AND A REAL
OPPORTUNITY THERE AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE ALL HERE TODAY I
THINK IT'S THE THINK ABOUT-
REAL POLLUTION. PROBLEM NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. SO WE REALLY NEED
TO DECIDE WHAT FUTURE WE WANT
FOR OUR OCEANS AND FOR
OURSELVES AND THIS ISN'T JUST
ABOUT THE AMOUNT WE CAN REDUCE
FROM TODAY'S PRODUCTION LEVELS
THAT TALKED ABOUT PREVENTING
THE DOUBLING OF THE AMOUNT JUST
IN THE NEXT COUPLE DECADES SO
WE NEED TO- FIRST OF ALL REDUCE
THE AMOUNT THAT WE'RE PRODUCING
AND THE AMOUNT THAT'S GOING
INTO THE OCEAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT- WE CAN HAVE A VIBRANT
BEAUTIFUL OCEAN THAT THE
FUTURE- AND WITH THAT I THINK
WE'RE AT THE END OF THIS
SECTION. SO WE'LL BE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND SINCE YOU ARE THE
LAST PANELIST YOU'RE GOING TO
GET I THINK RELEASED MY FIRST
QUESTION. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION IT WAS VERY VERY
SOBERING. SO IF US I HAVE A
HYPOTHETICAL QUESTION ASSUMING
THAT WE STOPPED ALL PLASTIC
POLLUTION GOING INTO THE OCEANS
TODAY LET'S SAY WE COULD JUST
NOT WAVE A MAGIC WAND THAT I
WISHED I HAD. HOW WE CAN STOP
THE PRODUCTION OF PLASTIC AND
STOP IT FROM GOING IN THE
OCEANS. HOW DO WE CLEAN UP THE
TRASH THAT'S ALREADY IN THERE
WHAT IT WILL IS THERE A WAY TO
ROLL BACK THOSE IMPACTS IS IT
SOMETHING THAT WILL DISSIPATE
OVER TIME OR IS THAT DAMAGE
JUST DONE UNTIL WE COME UP WITH
SOME BRAND NEW TECHNOLOGY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION THAT ONE I THINK MANY
ARE THINKING ABOUT. I DON'T
HAVE A PERFECT ANSWER ONE THING
THAT WE DO WELL IS AS I SAID IN
THE BEGINNING THE OCEANS DO YOU.
STING PLASTIC BACKED OUT. SO
MUCH OF THAT IS SO FINE LITTLE
CLASSICS THAT IT IS A REALLY
NEAR IMPOSSIBLE TO CLEAN UP AND
THEN BE. WE'LL HAVE A LOOK AT
OTHER WAYS TO CLEAN UP WHILE IN
THE OCEAN I'M SURE MANY MANY
HAVE HEARD OF THE GREAT OCEAN
CLEANUP PROJECT WHICH NOT A LOT
OF- FUNDING TO LOOK AT
POTENTIALLY CLEANING UP
CLASSICAL ABOUT ME OCEAN- BUT
IF IT IS A REAL PROBLEM EVEN IF
WE STOP ALL CLASSIC TODAY THE
CLEAN UP BY THE THINGS IS
SOMETHING THAT. WE HAVE NOT WE
HAVE NOT FIGURED OUT YET AND I
WOULD TURN MY OTHER PANELISTS
TO SEE IF THEY HAVE- ANY OTHER
THOUGHTS BUT IT IT. THANK YOU
I'M GONNA ASK IF ANY OF MY-
COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FOR THIS PANEL IS WHY DON'T WE
DO A PANELIST BY PANELIST IF
POSSIBLE. MAKE IT A LITTLE
EASIER ON EVERYBODY. OKAY MR
MCCARTY BONTA ON THIS SPEAKER
YES JUST SPEAKER THEM
ALTOGETHER SO SURE- YOU KNOW
CLEARLY WHAT YOU'RE OUTLINING.
ARE THE IMAGES THAT THAT WE ALL
SEE AND THAT DOES NOT GET ALL
OF OUR- HEARTS NO MATTER. HOW
YOU THINK ABOUT. THE PLASTIC
SEVENTY ONE THE PLASTICS
INDUSTRY IT DISTURBS THEM
SAYING. ANIMALS YOU KNOW HARD
IN AND THEY- SAID AND THE
IMPACT TO OUR- ENVIRONMENT WE-
QUESTIONS FOR YOU ON ON THE-
HEALTH IMPACTS. IT WITH WHAT
WAS A TURNING POINT. YOU KNOW
PEOPLE ARE DISTURBED SEEING THE
PICTURE OF THE TURTLE- THE BIRD
AND THEN THEY GO BACK AND GET
THAT STARBUCKS LATTE AND JUST
GO ON WITH OUR LIVES RIGHT. BUT
AT SOME POINT WHEN THERE IS AN
IMPACT ON OUR- ON OUR HEALTH-
YOU KNOW THAT'S A PEOPLE START
TO REALLY MAKE DECISIONS BUT
DIFFERENTLY. SO WHAT WHAT'S
HAPPENED THE LAST FEW YEARS AS
FAR AS THE- AS FAR AS THE-
LOOKING AT THE REAL IMPACT OR
IS IT TOO EARLY IS IT GOING TO
BE YOU KNOW. DECADES DOWN THE
ROAD DECADES DOWN THE ROAD.
HELP YOUR BACK BUTTON FOR ME
YEAH THESE THE QUESTIONS ARE
ALL FOR YOU RIGHT NOW AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO THE NEXT
PANELISTS JUST TO MAKE IT A
LITTLE EASIER. OKAY WONDERFUL
THANK YOU I'M SORRY YEAH. ONE
MOMENT ONE MOMENT CHECK WAS FOR
CHELSEA OR FORD. WAS IS FOR
CHELSEA OR FOR TERROR PROP FROM
OSHANA- I THINK OKAY LAST
SPEAKER. THIS ACTUALLY IS OVER
TERROR BRAUCHT. SORRY THAT'S
OKAY. YOU CAN ANSWERED AFTER AS
WELL. MS BROCK ARE YOU THERE.
LOOKS LIKE HERE HAS
DISCONNECTED OKAY
INTERVENTIONAL THEN THIS ROTH A
PROFESSOR YOU'RE ON. OKAY SO I
WOULD IT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION RIGHT MOST OF THE
INFORMATION WE HAVE RIGHT NOW
IS ABOUT AND HOW MICROPLASTICS
OR PLASTIC POLLUTION IN GENERAL
IMPACT WILDLIFE BUT AS YOU KNOW
IN CALIFORNIA THERE'S A BILL
THAT SAYS THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE
TO DEFINE MICROPLASTICS
RELEVANT YOU DRINKING WATER
EVENTUALLY WE NEED TO HAVE A
METHOD TO QUANTIFY IT IN
DRINKING WATER WHICH MEANS WE
HAVE TO KNOW HOW MUCH IT TOO
MUCH THOUGH THAT WHAT WE-
MEASURE THAT AMOUNT WE CAN SAY
WHETHER OR NOT IT MEANS WE NEED
TO DO SOMETHING IN TERMS OF THE
AMOUNT OF DRINKING WATER SO
THERE'S A WORKING GROUP RIGHT
NOW. I IN CALIFORNIA OF EXPERTS
FROM AROUND THE WORLD YOU
COMING TOGETHER TO SURVEY THE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE THERE
IS SOME RESEARCH ON
MICROPLASTICSIN HUMAN HEALTH
BUT IT'S LIMITED I TRY TO COME
UP WITH THOSE NUMBERS SO YOUR
QUESTION IS GOOD AND I WOULD
SAY THAT IN ABOUT FIVE OR. SIX
MONTHS WE HOPE TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER IT. OKAY THANK YOU- I
HAVEN'T ANOTHER QUESTION THIS
IS FOR FRANKLY FOR ANYBODY HERE
BUT I WAS STRUCK BY THE VERY
FIRST- SLIDE FROM THE ELADIO
WHICH WAS TALKED ABOUT HOW. THE
AMOUNT OF PLASTIC- WASTE OUR
LANDFILLS AND IN GENERAL HAS
INCREASING BECAUSE MOST THE
PUBLIC THINKS WE RECYCLE IT
IT'S ALL GOOD JUST THERE THAT
WAS GOING FOR A WALK IN THEIR
KIDS. HEY PROTECT THE
REFILLABLE WATER BOTTLES NOT
NOT THOSE ARE THE ONES IS
AVAILABLE TO RECYCLE THAT'S
FINE IT'S ALL GOOD AND- WE
THINK THAT. THAT'S WHY HAVE THE
BIG BAND BUT IT DOES ALWAYS-
WORK THAT WAY AND I AND I LIKE
WITH THE FIRST SPEAKER TALKED
ABOUT HOW YOU KNOW THE HIGH
COST OF LOW PRICES DOLLAR
STORES EVERYTHING IS. PLASTIC
AND DISPOSABLE AND IT'S SUPER
CHEAP BUT PEOPLE THINK I'LL
THROW IT IN THE BLUE BAND. IT'S
ALL GOING TO BE- ALL GONNA BE
RECYCLED SO. YOU KNOW IT WHAT
DO WE NEED TO DO TO. FROM THE
PUBLIC TO HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING THAT ALL THE
STUFF IS NOT. RECYCLE I THINK
THAT HISTORICALLY WE JUST
THINK. THAT BLUE BANDS GONNA
SOLVE ALL OF OUR WELLS PUT
EVERYTHING IN THAT LOOP AND
EVERYTHING BE RECYCLED SO- IS
IT JUST A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING. FROM FROM FROM
THAT POLICY MAKERS AND FOR THE
PUBLIC AS FAR AS WHAT IS.
RECYCLABLE THAT THAT HINDERS
OUR ABILITY TO BRING ABOUT.
CHANGE MAYBE IT ISN'T A
QUESTION IS THE STATEMENT BUT-
I THINK THAT'S YOU KNOW A BIG
ISSUE THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
IN THIS IN THE SPACE. IF
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO- SAY
SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN'T THAT
WE CAN FIND. SO ANYBODY WANTS
TO COMMENT ON THAT- FEEL FREE
IF NOT WE CAN JUST GO TO THE
NEXT QUESTION I'M TOLD THAT-
TERROR PROFITS BACK ON AS WELL.
OKAY I THINK WE'RE GOOD- I
GUESS I'LL JUST ASK A FEW
QUESTIONS- FOR I KNOW THAT
PROFESSOR. ROTHMAN IS THERE MY
QUESTION IS WHAT WE KNOW
WHETHER WE KNOW MUCH ABOUT THE
EFFECT OF THE MICRO PLASTICS ON
HUMAN HEALTH AND I'VE READ THAT
THERE IS SOME LINK PERHAPS TO
PLASTIC BEING AN ENDOCRINE
DISRUPTOR AND POSSIBLE- IMPACTS
TO HUMAN HEALTH WITH ENDOCRINE
DISRUPTION BUT I'M WONDERING
HOW MUCH WE ACTUALLY KNOW. HOW
MUCH WE HAVE A PRETTY GOOD IDEA
THAT WE KNOW AND WHAT WE SHOULD
HOW WE SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT
PLASTICS AND THEIR IMPACT ON
HUMAN HEALTH. YEAH I WOULD SAY
THAT WHAT WE KNOW RIGHT NOW IS
WE KNOW WE'RE EXPOSED SO
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT WE DRINK
MICROPLASTICS IN WATER. WE EAT
IT WITH OURS THE FOOD AND IT'S
INVEST SO WE ALSO BEAT IT WHEN
IT LANDS ON THE FOOD THAT WE'RE
EATING OR POTENTIALLY IN HELL
IT. AYE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND RIGHT NOW IS THAT
THE STATE OF IT IN THE BODY WE
KNOW THAT IT CAN TRANSFER FROM
THE GUIDE INTO. THE CIRCULATORY
SYSTEM AND THEN INTO THE LIVER
AND WE SEE IT SOMETIMES THE
MUSCLE TISSUE OF FISH. AT THAT
THERE'S EVIDENCE THAT THE
SMALLER THE PLASTIC IS YOU HAVE
THIS SYSTEMIC AVAILABILITY. IN
THE BODY- WE KNOW MORE. HOW
THAT IMPACTS FISH AND OTHER
ORGANISMS THAN WE DO FOR
HUMANS. PART OF THAT REASON IS
WE CAN'T EXPERIMENT WITH HUMAN-
BUT THERE'S BEEN SOME STUDIES
ON MICE THAT HAVE SHOWN THAT
THESE MICROPLASTICS CAN LEAD TO
INFLAMMATION. THAT THEY CAN
CHANGE AND GREEN EXPRESSIONS
THAT YOU ASK IF THEY CAN IN
INTERACT WITH THE ENDOCRINE
SYSTEM. IN HUMANS THAT HAPPENED
AND LOOK AT IT KIND IT'S
MOSTLY. I JEAN EXPO THAT ARE
RELEVANT TO THE NEEDS SYSTEM
FUNCTION. BUT IN FISH WE HAVE
BEEN. EVIDENCE OF ENDOCRINE
DISRUPTION RELEVANT Q. CHANGES
IN GENE EXPRESSION THAT ARE
RELEVANT TO HOW MANY EGGS CAN
LAY AND ALSO. I CHANGES IN THAT
GOMEZ AT EMAIL FISH EXPECTING
FEMININE CHARACTERISTICS SO.
THEY CAN INTERACT WITH A
DIFFERENT SYSTEM HOW MUCH THEY
DO IN HUMANS OUR STILL IS TO
HAVE A BIT LEARN. THANK YOU- BY
OTHER IS BESIDES IT SOUNDS LIKE
WE NEED TO DO MORE RESEARCH ON
THE EFFECT OF- OF MICROPLASTICS
IN HUMAN HEALTH AND WE ALSO
TALKED ABOUT HOW WE NEED TO
CERTAINLY DO A LOT MORE
RESEARCH ABOUT HOW TO DEAL WITH
THE OR REMOVE THE PLASTICS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY IN THE OCEAN IF
OR ANY OTHER AREAS OF RESEARCH
THAT YOU WISH WE WERE-
INVESTING MORE AND I MEAN WHAT
ELSE WHAT ARE THE OTHER BIG
UNKNOWNS THAT ARE OUT THERE
THAT WE SHOULD BE. LOOKING AT.
I THINK THE THING THAT THAT I
WOULD STAY IT RUNS. AND THIS
ISN'T ABOUT. IT ISN'T ABOUT THE
IMPACT BUT I THINK IT'S ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING. IN
ORDER KIDS THINK ABOUT THE MOST
THAT. MISSION AFFECTED WAY TO
ACT. IF THEY THINK WE NEED
LOCAL MONETARY SO I WAS
INVOLVED IN A STUDY IN SAN
FRANCISCO BAY. LOOKING AT MICRO
PLASTICS AND WE LEARNED A LOT
ABOUT ROAD RUNOFF THAT. WE
THOUGHT WHAT THE TIRE THAT'S
COMING IN STORMWATER. ABOUT THE
MICROFIBERS WITH WATER
TREATMENT PLANTS WE KNOW THAT'S
IMPORTANT PATH WHERE SPORTS
INDICATED. I THINK IF WE START
LOCAL MONITORING PROGRAMS WE
CAN UNDERSTAND THE SOURCES.
WHICH CAN HELP FORCE REDUCTION
AT THE SAME TIME OF COURSE WE
NEED TO KEEP RESEARCHING. THE
IMPACT ECOSYSTEMS AND HUMAN
HEALTH BUT THAT ON GOING. AND I
THINK UNDERSTANDING THE COURSES
CAN HELP BACK AND. START THE
MITIGATION PROCESS. THANK YOU I
MEAN I'M TO. MS LEON GROW. WHO
I THINK TO AN ONE OF THE
PREVIOUS QUESTIONS THAT WAS
ASKED. ARE YOU THERE. YES I'M
HERE- I WANTED TO ANSWER
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MCCARTHY'S
QUESTION ABOUT- YOU KNOW WHAT
CAN WE DO ABOUT THE FACT THAT A
LOT OF RECYCLING AND SUB BEING
LANDFILLED. AND I THINK IT WAS
THE REASON WE ARE HERE WAS
BECAUSE OF AN INTENTIONAL
CAMPAIGN BY THE INDUSTRY.
PUTTING THE BURDEN BACK ON OFF
THE CONSUMERS AND IT JUST FEELS
GOOD TO PUT STUFF IN THE
RECYCLING BIN I EVEN SEE MORE
RECYCLING BINS I SEE TWO OR
EVEN THREE. RECYCLING BINS WHEN
I GO FOR A WALK- AND PEOPLE
JUST THINK YOU KNOW JUST BEFORE
CARPORT THERE I JUST PUT MORE
CLASSICS THERE AND EVERYTHING'S
GOING TO YOU KNOW GO AND GET
RECYCLED. EVEN THOUGH THAT
MIGHT NOT BE TRUE UNTIL I THINK
THE ONLY WAY TO COMBAT THAT IS.
A CAMPAIGN TO INFORM THE PUBLIC
THIS IS THE REALITY OF THINGS-
THERE'S ALSO ALSO THE FACT THAT
A LOT MORE PEOPLE MIGHT BE
ORDERING STUFF ONLINE- SO THAT
YOU KNOW THEY JUST THINK WE'LL
ALL JUST RECYCLE. THAT INSTEAD
OF- YEAH. PURCHASING WITH MY
AND MORE FOR CONSCIENCE AND HOW.
DO WE IMPLEMENT. POLICIES THAT
ARE NOT GOING TO AFFECT. HOW
PEOPLE BUY IT AND OTHER
BEHAVIOR SO AGAIN I THINK IT
JUST GOES TO. SHOW THAT- YOU
KNOW. COMMUNICATIONS FROM OUR
THE INDUSTRY ARE WORKING WELL
AND PUTTING YOU KNOW THINGS ON
ON A ON A BLOOP AND- JUST MAKES
PEOPLE FEEL GOOD AND- AND
THAT'S THE END OF IT BUT HE'S
CLEARLY NOT THE SOLUTION AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE IN THE POINT-
AND TIMES THAT WE ARE RIGHT NOW
AND HE'S- FROM. GOING TO GET
WORSE IF WE DON'T ACT NOW I
HAVE A QUESTION I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU WHY YOU'RE
HERE. WHEN WE TRY TO TALK TO
INDUSTRY OR PASSED BILLS OR
LEGISLATION. CURBING THE USE OF
PLASTIC OR MANDATING MORE
RECYCLED CONTENT INTO. PRODUCTS
THAT ARE BEING PRODUCED THE
INDUSTRY USUALLY RESPONDS BY
COMING BACK AND SAYING WELL IF
WE DO THIS IS GOING TO MAKE OUR
PRODUCTS SO MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE
AND THAT'S GONNA HURT LOW
INCOME PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY
WON'T BE ABLE TO AFFORD. TO
PURCHASE THESE PRODUCTS ANYMORE
AND I'M WONDERING HOW YOU WOULD
ANSWER. THAT ARGUMENT. WELL I
MEAN THERE'S SOME INDUSTRY THAT
UNDOUBTEDLY WILL HAVE TO GO
AWAY JUST BECAUSE THE- BUSINESS
MODEL THAT THEY HAVE. THE
ANSWER TO OUR- POLLUTION
ESPECIALLY PLUS A SINGLE USE
PLASTIC POLLUTION. IS TO CUT IT
AT THE SOURCE. AND WE KNOW THAT
THE PLASTIC INDUSTRIES HIGHLY
AUTOMATED. SO WHAT WE NEED TO
DO IS JUST REALLY. GO BACK TO
REUSABLE AND THAT'S A NEW TYPE
OF ECONOMY AN ECONOMY THAT WE
NEED TO BE PROMOTING.
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY- I GREW UP
IN MEXICO CITY WHERE EVERYTHING
PRETTY MUCH- ESPECIALLY
BEVERAGES WHERE. A REUSABLE AND
WE JUST STARTED ANYTHING THEY-
WILL REFILL IT. SO WE KNOW THAT
IT'S POSSIBLE IF THE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST. CITIES IN THE WORLD
CAN DO IT. I KNOW CALIFORNIA
CAN DO IT. SO IT'S JUST A
DIFFERENT WAY OF DOING
BUSINESS. AND WE JUST NEED TO
CHANGE WE CANNOT AFFORD TO KEEP
DOING WHAT WE'RE DOING. AND WE
KNOW THAT PEOPLE GETTING HURT
FROM EXTRACTION. TO THE WAY
THAT WE'RE PRODUCING THE
MATERIALS OF THE WAY WE'RE
CONSUMING WE KNOW LOW INCOME
PEOPLE GETTING HURT WITH
DIFFERENT DISEASES CANCER AND
EVEN DEATH. SO THAT WOULD BE MY
ANSWER. GREAT THANK YOU. I
WOULD ASK MY- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
IF THEY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
GOVERNMENT'S GARCIA. THIS THANK
YOU I. WE ARGUED TALKED US
ABOUT HOW MICROPLASTICS ARE
FOUND IN OUR SEAFOOD AND IN OUR
WATER CAN YOU ELABORATE ON
OTHER PRODUCTS THAT WERE
CONSUMING THAT ALSO ARE ALSO
CONTAMINATED WITH MICROPLASTICS
THE PROBLEM MUCH WETTER THAN
TO. RECEIVE FOOD. WELL I CAN
ANSWER THE QUESTION COMES UP I
MEAN OR EVEN FREEZING
MICROPLASTICS AT THIS POINT
BECAUSE OF THE PREVALENCE. OF
IS EVEN IN THE RAIN IT'S
EVERYWHERE AT THIS POINT SO AND
WE KNOW EVEN IN THE FISH IS NOT
JUST IN THEIR GUTS EVEN UNDER
SKIN. SO WE KNOW WE'RE-
CONSUMING MAP OF MICROPLASTICS
IN IN MORE WAYS THAT WE CAN
EVEN THINK OFF- AND IT'S JUST
GOING TO KEEP. GROWING THE
PROBLEM IS GOING TO KEEP
GROWING ON UNLESS WE TAKE
ACTION AND WE TAKE IT SWIFTLY.
DO WE HAVE ANY SORT OF ACTUAL
LIKE I BELIEVE YOU REALLY START
THAT AND I DON'T BELIEVE WE
COULD RECYCLE OUR WAY OUT OF
THIS PROBLEM I DO BELIEVE. SO
HE'S WILL BACK TO ELEMENTARY
CAMPAIGN- EDUCATIONAL CAMPAIGN
THAT WE HAD WHEN I WAS GROWING
UP THE REDUCE. REUSE RECYCLE. I
RECYCLE BIN OUR LAST OPTION. I
THEIR- BOB BIG ARE WE ARE WE
TRY. SINCE I'M MORE SYSTEMIC
WAY SO THAT WE CAN MAKE THAT
CASE. TO THE PUBLIC OF YOU KNOW
WHAT ELSE WE FIND IT IN AT WHAT
LEVELS IF I NEEDED TO BE ON.
THESE TWO ITEMS I BELIEVE THAT
IT'S MUCH WIDER THAN AND
JUSTICE BUT DO WE HAVE SOME
SORT OF. ACTUAL DATABASE GOING
IN THE SAME THING THAT ARE
POLLUTION THAT WE HAVE A
METRIC. IN OUR POLLUTION
TRACKERS OUT THERE. I MEAN WE
HAVE LIKE I PERCENT- THE
CALIBER SCREEN THAT WE KNOW
THAT- POLLUTION IS HURTING OUR
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE. THE OIL
WELLS ARE CONNECTED TO PLASTIC
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
GETTING THE PLASTIC. AND I MEAN
WE CAN DO A STUDY IN TERMS OF
THE LIFE CYCLE HOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE GETTING HURT BY. THE
PLASTICS ECONOMY. AND HOW MUCH
WE CAN SAVE. NOT ONLY BY
HOLDING OUT THE WASTE BUT ALSO-
HOW MUCH MONEY WE CAN SAVE IN
TERMS OF HEALTH SAVINGS. FOR
ALL THE PEOPLE WERE GETTING
SICK RIGHT NOW FROM THE CYCLE.
BUT IT DIDN'T TAKE IN THE
CALAVERAS SCREENER IS THERE A
METRIC FOR MICROPLASTICS RIGHT
NOW. AND. SHOULD BE ALSO THE
CONVERSE SCREEN THERE'S NO
OVERLAY- IN TERMS OF LIKE WHERE
ALL THE OIL WELL FIRE I DID
THAT MYSELF BUT I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE CONGRESSMAN
TO HAVE. THERE'S BEEN READING
ABOUT HOW- OIL COMPANIES ARE
INVESTING MORE INTO PETROL
CHEMICALS THAT ARE MOVING MORE
THEIR BUSINESS IN THAT
DIRECTION AS- MAYBE OTHER.
TRADITIONAL SOURCES OF OIL
CONSUMPTION HAS HAS BEEN GOING
DOWN. AND THEY'VE WE'VE SEEN.
THAT DOLLARS THAT THEY'VE
INVESTED IN SELLING AS THE IDEA
OF RECYCLING. AS AN OPTION OF
PUTTING THINGS INTO THE BLUE
BIN EVEN THOUGH THE SUN TEMPLE
SETS UP THE SEXY BEING
RECYCLED. DO WE KNOW F. AS
THEIR SINUSES IDEA RECYCLING IS
ACTUALLY TRYING TO INVEST IN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO RECYCLE
THIS MATERIAL. SPENDING MORE
THAN ANYTHING TO SPENDING
ADVERTISING DOLLARS TRYING TO
SELL US ON THE IDEA OF
RECYCLING. OTHER PROBABLY GOING
TO SPEND SOME MONEY ON
RECYCLING PLANTS KNOWING THAT
THE MORE THEY CONVINCE US ALL
THAT RECYCLING WORKS THE MORE
THEY CAN PUSH MORE PLASTICS SO
YEAH. OKAY THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO ANY OF THE
PANELISTS- MISTER MURATSUCHI IF
YOU'RE THERE IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS PLEASE. FIND A WAY TO
LET US KNOW. OKAY WILL MOVE
INTO OUR NEXT PANEL I'D LIKE TO
THANK OUR FIRST PANEL THAT WAS
VERY SOBERING AND REALLY IMPORT
INFORMATION SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. OUR SECOND PANEL IS
ON THE MANAGEMENT OF PLASTICS
AT THE LOCAL AND AT THE STATE
LEVEL WE'RE GONNA BE JOINED BY
RITA CAPITALIST WITH THE
LAWSUIT WHO IS THE LOS ANGELES
CHIEF SUSTAINABILITY OFFICER.
JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO WE HELLER
WITH CAL RECYCLE CAL RECYCLE.
FOR WE CAN HAVE OUR FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE. FIRST WITNESS
WILL BE RITA TEMPLE OFF. THESE
IN THE REMOTE IF THERE YOU ARE
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE YOUR
POWER POINT ON OUR SCREEN WE
CAN SEE YOU AND WE CAN SEE THE
POWER POINT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU. OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. A GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARES FRIEDMAN
MCCARTY AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ONCE AGAIN MY NAME IS RITA
COMPLEMENT AND I'M WITH LA
COUNTY'S CHIEF SUSTAINABILITY
OFFICE- START OFF I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR ALLOWING ME
TO BE PART OF TODAY'S PANEL.
AND AS JUST A VERY BRIEF
BACKGROUND ABOUT OUR OFFICE.
OUR OFFICE WAS FORMED SEVERAL
YEARS AGO BY THE COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS WITH OUR MAIN
CHARGE BEING TO CREATE THE
COUNTIES FOR SUSTAINABILITY
PLAN WHICH WE'RE PROUD TO SAY
WAS ADOPTED. LAST YEAR BY OUR
BOARD- NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. OKAY
GREAT THE GOAL FOR THE PLAN WAS
TO OUTLINE AN AMBITIOUS A
COMPREHENSIVE AND REGIONAL
VISION FOR SUSTAINABILITY FOR
THE COUNTY WHICH IS CAPTURED IN
THE PLANTS TWELVE HIGH LEVEL
CROSS SECTORAL GOALS WHICH YOU
SEE HERE YOU CAN GO TO NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE- I WILL DEFINITELY
NOT GO THROUGH ALL OF THESE BUT
WHAT I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT IS
THAT AS WE WENT THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF PLANNED DEVELOPMENT.
WASTE MANAGEMENT AND SINGLE USE
PLASTIC WASTE IN PARTICULAR
ROSE UP TO THE TOP AS KEY
PRIORITIES FOR THE COUNTY TO
ADDRESS. SO THAT IS WHY WE
ENDED UP WITH THE GOLD WHICH IS
THE THIRD ONE DOWN THAT YOU SEE
I'M IN THE BLUE BOX- CENTERED
ON HOW WE MANAGE AND HOW TO
MINIMIZE WASTE SO SUSTAINABLE
PRODUCTION CONSUMPTION OF
RESOURCES. IN ADDITION THOUGH I
ALSO WANTED TO NOTE THAT
ANOTHER GOAL WHICH IS MAYBE THE
ONE THAT'S CAPTURED THE MOST
ATTENTION FROM OUR PLAN- IS THE
FIRST ONE WHICH IS FOR A FOSSIL
FUEL FREE L. A. COUNTY. THAT
HOUSING ASSOCIATED TARGET FOR
CARBON NEUTRALITY FOR THE
COUNTY. BY TWENTY FIFTY. IN
LINE WITH THE STATE GOALS OF
COURSE AS WELL AS OUR BOARD
STATED COMMITMENT TO THE PARIS
CLIMATE AGREEMENT. WE SEE
TACKLING OUR WASTE MANAGEMENT
CHALLENGES IN PARTICULAR
ADDRESSING SINGLE USE PLASTICS
AS KEY TO ACHIEVING THESE
GOALS- AS HAS BEEN NOTED BY
SPEAKERS BEFORE ME- AS THE
WORLD IS SLOWLY MOVING AWAY
FROM FOSSIL FUELS AS AN ENERGY
SOURCE. OIL COMPANIES ARE
RAMPING UP PRODUCTION OF THESE
PLASTICS AND- PLASTIC
MATERIALS. SO IT'S REALLY
INCUMBENT UPON US TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO EFFECTIVELY MANAGE THESE
MATERIALS BECAUSE THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE NOW ARE ONLY
GONNA GET. BIGGER IN THE
FUTURE. SO NEXT LIFE PLEASE.
ALL THAT SAID- THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT THE COUNTY HAS TRIED TO
TACKLE OVER THE YEARS. SO ONE
OF THE FIRST EFFORTS WAS A BAN
ON EXPANDED POLYSTYRENE FOOD
CONTAINERS- THAT WAS LIMITED TO
COUNTY FACILITIES. AND SHORTLY
AFTER THAT WE ARE ABLE TO PASS
A PLASTIC BAG BAN FOR COUNTY
AND UNINCORPORATED AREAS- AND
WE'RE PROUD TO SAY THAT WE ARE
THE LARGEST RISK. JURISDICTION
DO THAT AT THE TIME. MOST
RECENTLY JUST ABOUT A YEAR AGO
OUR BOARD ADOPTED A MOTION
DIRECTING OUR OFFICE TO LOOK AT
SINGLE USE FOODSERVICE WHERE.
SPECIFICALLY FIRST OFF WE WERE
DIRECTED TO CONTRACT WITH
UCLA'S LUSKIN SCHOOL OF POLICY
TO PUT TOGETHER A STUDY OF THE
SPECIFIC IMPACT THAT THESE
PRODUCTS HAVE ON L. A. COUNTY.
AND THEN FOLLOWING THAT TO
DRAFT AN ORDINANCE USING
STAKEHOLDER INPUT- SO NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. SO I'D LIKE TO
TAKE A MINUTE NOW TO JUST
DISCUSS SOME OF THE KEY POINTS%
FROM THE UCLA STUDY WHICH CAME
OUT IN JANUARY. SO THE STUDY
WAS BASED ON AN EXTENSIVE
LITERATURE REVIEW AS WELL AS
INTERVIEWS WITH A NUMBER OF KEY
STAKEHOLDERS SUCH AS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WASTE HAULERS AND
MATERIALS RECOVERY FACILITIES.
ALTHOUGH WE ARE VERY CONCERNED
WITH THE WELL KNOWN
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT OF THESE
MATERIALS WHICH ARE FIRST PANEL
DISCUSSED- WE'RE ALSO VERY MUCH
DRIVEN BY THE MORE RECENT
IMPACTS THE WASTE INDUSTRY ALSO
WITH SPRINT NOTED WITH THE
CHINA AS- YOU'RE STARTING WITH
CHINA'S NATIONAL SWORD POLICY-
AND SO A GOOD BIT OF THE UCLA
STUDY WAS REALLY FOCUSED ON
THAT WASTE MANAGEMENT ASPECT.
SO IN TERMS OF KEY FINDINGS.
FIRST OF OFFICE OFF WHAT THE
UCLA TEAM FOUND THROUGH
INTERVIEWS WAS. CONSISTENT WHAT
WE YOU KNOW WHAT WE HAD HEARD
THROUGH MEDIA AND OTHER
REPORTS. DESPITE THERE BEING
SEVERANCE SEVEN DIFFERENT TYPES
OF RESIN CODES FOR PLASTICS ALL
LABELED WITH FAMOUS CHASING
ARROW SYMBOL- ONLY TWO OF THOSE
CODES ONE AND TWO ARE COMMONLY
RECYCLED IN L. A. COUNTY-
ESPECIALLY WITHOUT THE
INTERNATIONAL MARKETS TO
SUPPORT- THE- RECYCLING FOR
THOSE OTHER PLASTICS. THEY NOW
AND UP IN THE LANDFILL. SECOND
REGARDLESS OF MATERIAL TYPE- NO
RECOVERY FACILITIES SERVING L.
A. COUNTY WAS FOUND TO
CONSISTENTLY RECYCLE SINGLE USE
FOODSERVICE WHERE SPECIFICALLY.
AND THIS IS BECAUSE OF A NUMBER
OF ISSUES INCLUDING.
CONTAMINATION WITH FOOD RESIDUE
AS WELL AS PRODUCT SIZE AND
MATERIAL. SO IT YOU KNOW IT'S
EASY TO FORGET THAT RECYCLING
IS REALLY A PHYSICAL PROCESS
AND AS A RESULT PRODUCT
CHARACTERISTICS LIKE SIZE SHAPE
COLOR WAIT. HOW CLEAN IT IS
REALLY CRITICAL FOR THAT
PROCESS TO WORK EFFECTIVELY. SO
YOU KNOW AGAIN WITH THE KEY
FINDINGS NOW LOOKING AT
ALTERNATIVES TO PLASTIC FOOD
SERVICE WHERE. A REUSABLE
UNSURPRISINGLY CAN HAVE IN A
HIGHER INITIAL CAPITAL COST
HOWEVER LONG TERM THEY'RE
EXPECTED TO HAVE PRETTY CLEAR
BENEFITS BOTH IN TERMS OF. THE
ENVIRONMENT AND ECONOMICALLY-
COMPOSTABLE WHERE WITH A LITTLE
BIT MORE COMPLICATED- WELCOME
POSSIBLE CAN BE BENEFICIAL FROM
A LIFE CYCLE PERSPECTIVE. AND
IN SOME WAYS WOULD BE AN EASIER
TRANSITION FOR SOME BUSINESSES
AS COMPARED TO RE USABLE THE
MATERIAL REALLY MATTERS. SO
WHILE THERE ARE CERT FOR
COMPOSTABLE MATERIALS AND
CERTAINLY MANY PRODUCTS THAT
LABEL THEMSELVES AS ECO
FRIENDLY- THERE IS A REAL
DISCONNECT BETWEEN THOSE LABELS
AND MESSAGING AND HOW THE
PROCESS ACTUALLY WORKS AT
COMPOSTING FACILITIES AND SO.
WHAT THE UCLA TEAM FOUND IS
THAT THE CLEAREST BENEFITS
REALLY CAME FROM A 100% FIBER
BASED. PRODUCTS WITHOUT ANY
CHEMICAL TREATMENTS. SO FINALLY
THE LAST POINT I WANT TO
MENTION IS ABOUT ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF SINGLE USE PLASTICS
AND ALTERNATIVES. FIRST LOOKING%
AT THE EXPERIENCE OF OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE MADE IT
SWITCHES TO- ALTERNATIVES OUT
THERE ORDINANCES ORDINANCES AND
SUCH. THE TEAM AGAIN CONFIRMED
WHAT'S BEEN REPORTED WHICH IS
THAT JURISDICTION'S REALLY
HAVEN'T SEEN ANY NEGATIVE AND
ECONOMIC IMPACTS TO BUSINESSES-
EITHER IN THE FORM OF BUSINESS
CLOSURES OR EVEN APPLICATIONS
FOR HARDSHIP WAIVERS. ON THE
OTHER HAND. A COST IMPACT TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND THE
WASTE INDUSTRY RESULTING FROM
CHANGES IN THE RECYCLING MARKET
AND HAVING TO MANAGE SOME OF
THESE MATERIALS HAVE BEEN
SEVERE- WELL WE CERTAINLY CAN'T
ATTRIBUTE ALL OF THOSE CHANGES
TO SINGLE USE. PLASTIC
FOODSERVICE WHERE ALONE- THERE
HAS BEEN A MASSIVE SHIFT IN THE
ECONOMIC CALCULUS OF RECYCLING
PROGRAMS IN RECENT YEARS. WHILE
RECYCLING WAS AT ONE TIME A
RELIABLE SOURCE OF REVENUE FOR
JURISDICTIONS THOSE REVENUES OF
EITHER AT DROPPED PRECIPITOUSLY
OR IN SOME CASES PROGRAM
SEVERAL ACTUALLY REQUIRED FUNDS
FROM JURISDICTIONS IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE. SO A QUICK EXAMPLE
FROM THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO THAT
THE UCLA STUDY SITES. WHILE THE
CITY IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
RECEIVED ABOUT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN REVENUE FROM ITS
RECYCLING OPERATIONS. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THAT WAS
REDUCED TO JUST SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. SO THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT ND IT'S LIKELY TO
GET WORSE- AND UNLESS SOMETHING
IS DONE TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
THAT DIFFERENCE. IS GOING TO
HAVE TO BE SHOULDERED BY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND RATEPAYERS
ULTIMATELY. ALL RIGHT NEXT
SLIDE. SO THERE ARE OF COURSE A
LOT INTERESTING POINTS IN THE
STUDY AND IT'S AVAILABLE ONLINE
FOR ANYONE WHO'S INTERESTED. IN
TAKING A LOOK BUT JUST TO CLOSE
THE LOOP WITH THE MOTION- YOU
KNOW WE WERE ON TRACK TO
RELEASE A DRAFT IN APRIL-
UNFORTUNATELY AS WE ALL KNOW
THE- PANDEMIC HIT IN MARCH. AND
AS OF NOW- YOU KNOW THEY'RE
PARTICULARLY DEVASTATING IMPACT
OF COURSE ON OUR LOCAL INTO.
LOCAL RESTAURANT INDUSTRY- AND
SO FOR NOW THE ORGANS
DEVELOPMENT IS CURRENTLY ON
HOLD. OKAY SAYS OUR NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. SO THAT'S SAID- WE ARE
THINKING ABOUT WAYS TO MOVE
FORWARD- THERE SOME KEY GAPS
AND NEXT STEPS IDENTIFIED
THROUGH. THE STUDY AND THERE
ARE WORK THAT I JUST WANT TO
LEAVE YOU WITH AND SO. ONE THAT
WAS THE NEED FOR CLEAR AND
CONSISTENT DEFINITIONS AND
STANDARDS FOR COMPOST ABILITY
AND RECYCLABILITY- THESE
DEFINITIONS REALLY NEED TO
ALIGN WITH THE REALITY OF WASTE
MANAGEMENT PROCESSES. AND
FURTHER IT DOES HAVE BEEN DRIVE
PRODUCT LABELING AND DESIGN YOU
KNOW CONSUMERS AND HAVE TO
BECOME EXPERTS IN MATERIAL
SCIENCE TO KNOW WHAT BINS TO
THROW THEIR FASHION- SECOND
WELL IT IS. INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
RECYCLING AND COMPOSTING WORK.
AS BEEN MENTIONED EARLIER THIS
IS NOT GONNA SOLVE OUR LITTLE
PART LITTER PROBLEM AS WELL AS
SOME OF THE THER SECEDED
ISSUES WITH PLASTIC PRODUCTION.
AND OUR TOP PRIORITY REALLY
NEEDS TO BE A REDUCING OVERALL
PRODUCTION OF WASTE. BOTH
THROUGH BETTER PRODUCT DESIGN
AS WELL AS FINDING WAYS TO
FACILITATE USE OF REUSABLE-
FUNDING FOR INSTREAM
INFRASTRUCTURE IS OF COURSE A
HUGE NEED- NOT JUST FOR NEW
FACILITIES BUT ALSO UPGRADED
EQUIPMENT SUCH AS OPTICAL
SORTERS A ROBOTIC SORTERS. AT
EXISTING FACILITIES WHICH CAN
REALLY IMPROVE- THE EFFICIENCY
OF THE RECYCLING PROCESS- AND
FINALLY AND THIS LAST ONE
REALLY TIES INTO EVERYTHING
ABOVE- THERE REALLY NEEDS TO BE
BETTER COLLABORATION WITH
PRODUCERS- AND IN GENERAL JUST
CONNECTING THAT CYCLE OF
PRODUCTION WITH THE AND LIFE OF
PRODUCTS. IT'S SIMPLY NOT
SUSTAINABLE TO ALLOW PRODUCERS
TO CREATE PRODUCTS WITHOUT ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR HOW THEY
WILL BE MANAGED AT THE END OF
THEIR LIFE. RIGHT NOW THAT'S
WHAT'S HAPPENING AND THE BURDEN
OF MANAGING THESE PRODUCTS AT
THE END OF THEIR LIFE IS NOW
FALLING ON LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
AND ULTIMATELY RATE PAYERS. SO
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
COLLABORATING WITH YOU ON THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF
YOU CAN STAND BY WE'LL HAVE
QUESTIONS AT THE END OF THE
PANEL DISCUSSION. NEXT WE HAVE
JOHN KENNEDY FROM THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND HE IS HERE
WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY CAN YOU HEAR ME- IS HE
HE'S ON HIS MIGHT. OKAY YEAH I
KNOW. ALL RIGHT. SO BEFORE I
START WANT TO GIVE YOU A VERY
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF MY
PRESENTATION TODAY. FIRST I
WANT TO COVER WHO WE ARE AND
HOW WE MANAGE SOLID WASTE AND
RECYCLABLES. IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA. NEXT FOCUS ON
CHALLENGES WITH MANAGING
PLASTIC WASTE AND LITTER AND
RURAL CALIFORNIA. AND THEN
THIRD FOCUS ON SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS GOING FORWARD.
SO ALL NOTE THAT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE COST OF SOLID WASTE
MANAGEMENT AND RECYCLING THESE
AREN'T JUST LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COSTS BUT THESE ARE COSTS THAT
ARE BORNE BY ALL RESIDENTS
LIVING WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AS L. A. COUNTY JUST ALLUDED
TO. SO TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
SOLID WASTE MANAGEMENT ROLE
CALIFORNIA WILL PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF OUR JURISDICTIONS.
WE HAVE THIRTY SEVEN WITH-
WORLD COUNTIES WITHIN RC RC
STRETCHING FROM THE OREGON
BORDER ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
MEXICO. WE RANGE IN POPULATION
FROM A LOW OF ABOUT ELEVEN
HUNDRED RESIDENTS IN ALCORN
COUNTY. TO ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND SONOMA COUNTY.
NINETEEN OF OUR COUNTIES ARE
UNDER SEVENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
AND FIVE HAVE UNDER FOURTEEN
THOUSAND SO WE'RE PRETTY SMALL
IN THE GRAND SCHEME OF THINGS.
SOME HAVE NO CITIES THREE HAVE
NO CITIES AND EIGHT HAVE ONLY A
SINGLE CITY. WE COVER LARGE
AREAS AND HAVE VERY LOW
POPULATION DENSITIES AND SO
THAT CAN PRESENT CHALLENGES FOR
SOLID WASTE COLLECTION- AND
RECYCLABLE COLLECTION AND
MANAGEMENT. AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE SOME VERY LOW MEDIAN
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES AND OUR
COMMUNITY IS COMPARED TO THE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE WHICH IS
ABOUT SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER HOUSEHOLD THIRTEEN
OF OUR COUNTIES HAVE A
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES BELOW FIFTY
THOUSAND PER YEAR. A HANDFUL
ARE BELOW FORTY TWO THOUSAND
YEAR. SO THIS IS ALL TO PAINT A
PICTURE THE CALIFORNIA HAS MANY
MANY MANY VERY DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS WE ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT NEEDS WE ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT CAPABILITIES. BUT WE
ALL SHARE SOME SIMILAR
EXPERIENCES AND SOLID WASTE
MANAGEMENT AND RECYCLING. SO
MOVING ON THURS THERE'S REALLY
NO SINGLE WAY TO DISCUSS.
DISCUSS OR DESCRIBE SOLID WASTE
MANAGEMENT RECYCLING IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA. SOME REAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE SERVED BY
FRANCHISE HAULERS THOSE
FRANCHISE HAULERS MAY OR MAY
NOT PROVIDE CURBSIDE COLLECTION
SERVICES FOR SOLID WASTE AND
RECYCLING. A LOT OF AREAS DON'T
HAVE CURBS AND- CAN'T REALLY
USE CURBSIDE COLLECTION
SERVICES SO SOME RURAL
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY THOSE
OUTSIDE OF THE HIGHER DENSITY
URBAN AREAS. MANAGE THEIR WASTE
EXCLUSIVELY THROUGH SELF
HAULING THAT MEANS THE RESIDENT
WILL TAKE THEIR OWN TRASH AND
RECYCLABLES. TO TRANSFER
STATION OR LANDFILL- AND MANAGE
THEIR WASTE THAT WAY. PLASTICS
AND PLASTICS AND OTHER
RECYCLABLES ARE SEPARATED BY
THE RESIDENTS AND THOSE- SELF
FALL JURISDICTIONS DROPPED OFF
EITHER IN DESIGNATED AREAS OF
THE TRANSFER STATION OR
LANDFILL OR DROPPED OFF AT
ANOTHER FACILITY ON THE WAY TO
THE LANDFILL OR TRANSFER
STATION. SO THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE FACE WHEN IT COMES TO
MANAGING PLASTIC WASTE THEIR
MANY CHALLENGES THE BIGGEST ONE
IS PROBABLY THE LACK OF END
MARKETS FOR THOSE MATERIALS. IT
OFTEN FEELS LIKE WE'RE ON A TWO
LEGGED STOOL WE COLLECT
MATERIALS AND WE SORT THEM BUT
THERE'S NO PLACE FOR THEM TO GO
ONCE WE'VE COLLECTED AND SORTED
THEM. SO IF THEY'RE IN MARKETS
WERE TYPICALLY PRETTY GOOD AT
MINING THE WASTE STREAM TO FIND
THOSE MATERIALS EXTRACT THEM
AND RECYCLE THEM. WE IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA SURE A LOT OF THE
SAME PROBLEMS WITH DIFFICULT TO
MANAGE AND DIFFICULT TO MARKET-
MATERIALS AS TO URBAN
COLLEAGUES BUT THOSE PROBLEMS
ARE OFTEN AND HANDS BECAUSE WE
LACK THE ECONOMIES OF SCALE
THAT ARE FOUND IN URBAN AREAS.
AND IT'S MORE EXPENSIVE TO
TRANSPORT THOSE MATERIALS OVER
GREATER DISTANCES PLASTICS ARE
TYPICALLY LIGHTER WEIGHT- SO
TAKES A LOT MORE VOLUME TO MOVE
THEM AND SOME OF THE NEAREST
MARKETS MAY ACTUALLY BE OUT OF
STATE. GIVEN OUR BORDER
COUNTIES. SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE
TO FOCUS ON A COUPLE OF THE-
MORE DIFFICULT TO MANAGE
MATERIALS THAT WE FIND IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA. THAT AREN'T- IS-
THAT'S WONDERFUL IN SOME URBAN
COMMUNITIES SO THERE ARE TWO
CHALLENGES AND A SUCCESS STORY-
THE FIRST CHALLENGE CONCERNS
AGRICULTURAL PLASTICS. AND I
WANT TO BE VERY CAREFUL IN
PRACTICE THIS DISCUSSION BY
SAYING PLASTICS OFTEN SERVE IN
A REALLY INTEGRAL ROLE IN
AGRICULTURE BOTH IN TERMS OF
PRODUCTION AND MARKETING. SO
I'M NOT HERE TODAY TO. SUGGEST
THAT WE PHASE OUT THE USE OF
PLASTICS IN AGRICULTURE- BUT I
THINK THIS PRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO INCREASE THE
USE AND RECYCLABILITY OF THOSE
MATERIALS THAT ARE USED IN THAT
SECTOR. SOME LOCAL SOLID WASTE
PROGRAMS HAVE RECEIVED
SIGNIFICANT QUANTITIES OF
AGRICULTURAL FILM THAT'S USED
IN PRODUCTION. UNFORTUNATELY
THERE AREN'T MANY MARKETS FOR
THOSE MATERIALS ALTHOUGH THERE
ARE A FEW MANUFACTURERS THAT
ARE TRYING TO TAKE THE
MATERIALS AND USE THEM TO
PRODUCE NEW REUSABLE SHOPPING
BAGS OR NEW AGRICULTURAL FILM.
THOSE ARE ACTIVITIES WE SHOULD
SUPPORT AND EXPAND GIVEN THE
ROLE THE PLASTIC PLAYS AND
PRODUCTION MARKETING. BECAUSE
WITHOUT MARKETS THE MATERIAL
GOES IN THE LANDFILL WORKING
ACTUALLY REALLY DIFFICULT TO
MANAGE IN THE LANDFILL
ENVIRONMENT. SIMILAR PROBLEMS
EXIST FOR PLASTIC IRRIGATION
LINE. THAT OFTEN WINDS UP IN
THE LANDFILL AND CAN POSE
SIGNIFICANT. MANAGEMENT
PROBLEMS TO. SOME OF OUR
COUNTIES HAVE A LOT OF THESE
MATERIALS COMING IN FROM
CANNABIS GROWS A LOT FROM
ILLEGAL CANNABIS GROWS AS WELL-
IN TRINITY COUNTY THEY SHARED
SOME EXAMPLES OF HELICOPTERS.
BRINGING AND BALES- IRRIGATION
LINE THAT WAS BROUGHT OUT OF
FEDERAL FOREST LANDS. SO MOVING
FROM THOSE MARINE DEBRIS IS A
PROBLEM IN SOME OF OUR COASTAL
AREAS THEY REPORTED PROBLEMS
WITH ABANDONED PLASTIC FISHING
GEAR INCLUDING NETTING BELIEVES
CAGES. THEY'RE LARGELY PLASTIC
BASE BUT THERE'S NO MARKET FOR
THEM ONCE WE CAN PULL THEM OUT
OF THE ENVIRONMENT AND SO
THEY'RE JUST GOING TO THE
LANDFILL. BUT THE SUCCESS STORY
IS PARTICULARLY INTERESTING TO
ME- IT CONCERNS PESTICIDE
CONTAINERS. SB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
THREE OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHT BY
SENATOR MALDONADO REQUIRES
PESTICIDE MANUFACTURERS TO
PARTICIPATE IN RECYCLING
PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT HDP
PESTICIDE CONTAINERS ARE
RECYCLED. LOCALS OFTEN COUNTIES
WHOSE PERIODICAL ACTION EVENT
AT WHICH THEY ACCEPT CERTIFIED
TRIPLE RINSE PESTICIDE
CONTAINERS THOSE ARE THEN
SHIPPED ON SITE AND HOLD OFF TO
BE RECYCLED. USUALLY MADE INTO
FENCE POST PALETTE SPEED BUMPS
MARINE PILINGS A LOT OF
PRODUCTS THAT REALLY HAVE VERY
LITTLE IF ANY INTERFACE WITH
THE GENERAL- CONSUMERS. SO
THEY'RE SAFE USES. THE PROGRAM
IS FUNDED BY MANUFACTURERS AND
IT'S BEEN REALLY INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL TO KEEP A LARGE
QUANTITIES PLASTICS OUT OF OUR
LANDFILLS. AND TO SEE THEM
RECYCLED IN THE NEWER PRODUCTS.
AND GOING TO LITTER LIKE SOME
OF OUR URBAN COLLEAGUES RURAL
AREAS HAVE SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM
WITH LITTER. ROADSIDE LITTER
WAS ONCE BOTTLES CANS AND PAPER
BUT IT'S NOW MUCH MORE PLASTICS
BASED INCLUDING FOOD PACKAGING.
SINGLE USE BAGS BLOWING IN THE
WIND CAN BE A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM IN HIGH WIND AREAS
ESPECIALLY MODEL COUNTY WE'VE
HEARD- AND I'VE HEARD FROM SOME
OF OUR MEMBERS AS SHIFT BACK TO
PAPER BAGS OF YESTERDAY COULD
HELP ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
PROBLEMS. ESPECIALLY WITH-RESPECT TO THE BAGS BLOWING IN
THE WIND AND THE NOT TO GRADING
IN THE ENVIRONMENT AND COULD
ALSO ADDRESS SOME OTHER
PROBLEMS WITH- THAT THE PAPER
MARKET FIVE MARKET. AND
LITTERING. CLEAN UP CAN BE
REALLY DIFFICULT AND COSTLY GOT
A COUPLE EXAMPLES SISKIYOU
COUNTY SO SPEND ABOUT SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR PINE.
LARGE TRASH BAGS FOR COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS TO GO OUT AND
PICK UP LITTER ALONG THE ROAD
AND THROUGHOUT THE COMMUNITY.
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS IS A LOT
OF MONEY FOR A COMMUNITY OF
ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
AND THEN MODOC COUNTY TRIES TO
HIRE INMATE CREWS WHERE THEY
CAN. TO GO OUT AND CLEAN UP
LATER. AND RELATED A LETTER.
ONE OF THE LONGEST AND MOST
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES MANY
RESIDENTS WHO HAD WITH PLASTIC
RECYCLING. IS THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM
THAT WE'VE HEARD ABOUT TODAY.
THE PROGRAM IS DESIGNED AND
INTENDED TO COMBAT LITTERED
BOTTLES AND CANS THAT HAVE NOW
SHIFTED PREDOMINANTLY TO
PLASTIC BUT THERE'S STILL A LOT
OF WOMEN ABOUT THEIR AND GLASS.
ROGAN HAS GENERALLY BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN RECYCLING
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS AND
REDUCING LETTER. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY MANY CONSUMERS
EXPERIENCES REALLY SOURED OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS BECAUSE OF
THE WIDESPREAD LACK OF
REDEMPTION OPPORTUNITIES. THIS
HITS ESPECIALLY HARD IN RURAL
AREAS. SOME COUNTIES HAVE NO
REDEMPTION OPPORTUNITIES
WHATSOEVER FOR THE RESIDENTS SO
WE'RE ACTUALLY SEEING MORE OF
THOSE BOTTLES AND CANS. GOING
TO THE LANDFILL WHERE BECOMES
REALLY EXPENSIVE TRASH. AND SO
THE REDEMPTION CENTER COLLAPSE
REALLY WHAT I'M TRYING TO SAY
HAS HAD A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON LOWER INCOME
RESIDENTS BOTH IN RURAL AREAS.
AND URBAN AREAS WHERE THE RATIO
OF CENTERS TO POPULATION IS
EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH. SO NEXT
ALL TURN TO RECOMMENDATIONS THE
FIRST RECOMMENDATION PERHAPS
THE STRONGEST RECOMMENDATION WE
HAVE TO INCREASE MANUFACTURING
GAUGE MINT. FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL DECADES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE BEEN CHARGED
WITH MEETING THE STATE SOLID
WASTE DIVERSION RECYCLING
REQUIREMENTS ALONE. THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AS YOU HEARD WE
HAVE NO CONTROL OVER WHAT ENDS
UP IN- IN THE MARKET PLACE. WE
NEED GREATER ENGAGEMENT BY
PRODUCT MANUFACTURERS WITH
RESPECT TO PRODUCT DESIGN AND
THE USE OF RECYCLED PRODUCTS
RECYCLED MATERIALS. FOR PRODUCT
DESIGN MANUFACTURE SHOULD FOCUS
ON DESIGNING PRODUCTS THAT ARE
READILY RECYCLABLE NOT JUST
THEORETICALLY RECYCLABLE AND
FOR WHICH THERE ARE MARKETS
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION AS WELL.
HOMOGENIZATION OF PACKAGING
MATERIALS COULD REDUCE
CONTAMINATION AND MAKE IT MUCH
EASIER TO FIND MARKETS FOR
THOSE CUTS. INCREASE IN THE USE
OF RECYCLED MATERIALS AND
PRODUCTS WILL INCREASE DEMAND
FOR PLASTICS COMING OUT OF THE
WAY SYSTEM. WE SHOULD FOCUS
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ON
CREATION OF. INNOVATIVE
PRODUCTS THAT USE LESS
MARKETABLE MATERIALS AND THAT
ARE SCALABLE CALTRANS IS
CURRENTLY USING SOME BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS AND PILOT PROJECTS
FOR ROAD PAVING THAT'S REALLY
INTRIGUING- BUT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE SOME COMPETITION FOR THOSE
MATERIALS. AS BEVERAGE
CONTAINER MANY FACTORS HAS TO
USE THEM TO COMPLY WITH EIGHTY
SEVEN NINETY THREE TEN FROM
LAST YEAR SO THERE'S A QUESTION
COULD CALTRANS USE OTHER TYPES
OF RESINS. SOME OTHER LESS
MARKETABLE MATERIALS FOR THOSE
PROJECT. IS THAT BETTER THAN
WHAT THEY'RE USING TODAY. AND
THEN. THROUGH THE CREATION OF
LOCAL AND DOMESTIC MARKETS- WE
CAN HELP MAXIMIZE BENEFITS FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT THE ECONOMY AND
JOB CREATION IN THE STATE SO
RATHER THAN SHIPPING OUR WASTE
OVERSEAS WHERE WE HOPE THAT IT
GETS RECYCLED INTO SOMETHING
ELSE LET'S FIND A WAY TO CREATE
JOBS HERE. AND THEN FINALLY ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I'VE HEARD
FROM A LOT OF OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BOTH FROM THE
SUPERVISORS AND FROM THE
RESIDENCE IS WE REALLY NEED
AFFECTS FROM BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING PROGRAM WE NEED TO
FIX THE PROGRAM TO ENSURE THEIR
ADEQUATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CONSUMERS TO REDEEM THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS TO GET THE
DEPOSIT BACK FIVE SOME SOME
TENCENT'S ADDS UP PRETTY
QUICKLY. AND TO MAKE THE
PROGRAM FLEXIBLE ENOUGH SO THEY
CAN TIMELY RESPOND TO ANY
CHALLENGES BOTH CHALLENGES ON
THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT WHERE YOU
HAVE CLOSURES OF RECYCLING
CENTERS AND ALSO MARKET
CONDITIONS SO WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY. IS SO WE HELLER
WITH CAL RECYCLE. AS SHE'S IN
THE VIDEO CONFERENCE FROM I
BELIEVE. THANK YEAH WE CAN HEAR
YOU AND WE CAN SEE YOUR POWER
POINT. OKAY GREAT. ALL RIGHT SO
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY FOR INVITING CAL
RECYCLE TO SPEAK AT THIS VERY
IMPORTANT HEARING TODAY. YOU
FOR THE OTHER PRESENTERS TO AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF FRAMING THE
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
PLASTICS ALL REINFORCE SOME OF
THE POINTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
TODAY. IN PROVIDE A PERSPECTIVE
REPRESENTING HELP RECYCLE DATA.
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES TO
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES THAT
PLASTICS ARE BRINGING TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT INTO OUR ENTIRE
MATERIALS MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
OKAY NEXT SLIDE. AS YOU'VE
HEARD PLASTICS GENERATION IS
INCREASING AS WE MOVE TOWARD
USING MORE SINGLE USE
DISPOSABLE PRODUCTS AND
PACKAGING. THERE'S INCREASED
COMPLEXITY OF PLASTIC PRODUCTS
ON THE MARKET SUCH AS
MULTILAYER MATERIALS FLEXIBLE
POUCHES IN SHRINK SLEEVE
LABELS. RESULTING IN MORE
MATERIALS DISPOSED IN
CONTAMINATION ISSUES IN THE
RECYCLING STREAM. EFFORTS TO
DATE WHETHER THROUGH MANDATORY
OR VOLUNTARY PROGRAMS HAVE NOT
BEEN SUFFICIENT TO STOP PLASTIC
FROM ENTERING CALIFORNIA'S
WATERWAYS AND THE OCEAN.
KARAKUL HAS GET ON PLASTIC
DISPOSAL AND SOME DATE ON
PLASTIC BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING FROM BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM
RUSSIA SOME OF THAT IN HIS
INTRODUCTORY PRESENTATION. AND
WE HAVE SOME ANECDOTAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE INCREASE
IN PLASTICS SUCH AS SINGLE USE
PLASTIC FOOTWEAR ITEMS PP AND
PLASTIC PACKAGING. MUCH OF THIS
HAS BEEN EXACERBATED BY COVERT
NINETEEN. COVERS LIKE WILL HAVE
SOME ADDITIONAL DATA ON
RECYCLING FROM OUR NEW
RECYCLING AND DISPOSAL
REPORTING SYSTEM. HOWEVER
ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY WOULD BE
NEEDED FOR CAL RECYCLE TO
OBTAIN A MORE COMPLETE PICTURE
OF PLASTIC PRODUCTION AND
RECYCLING IN THE STATE. YOU'VE
ALREADY HEARD THAT OF ALL THE
PLASTIC WASTE GENERATED ONLY
ABOUT 9% IS RECYCLED. 12% WAS
INCINERATED IN THE- 79% THAT
WAS LEFT WAS EITHER CUMULATED
LANDFILLS OR SKIPPED INTO THE
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT. CURRENTLY
42% PLASTIC PRODUCED COMES IN
THE FORM OF PACKAGING. AND MOST
OF THAT- IS DISPOSED WITHIN THE
SAME YEAR THAT IT WAS BLACK.
IT'S IMPORTANT NOTE THAT
PLASTIC IS A SIGNIFICANT PART
OF THE WASTE MANAGEMENT
RECYCLING CHALLENGES THE STATE
IS FACING BUT WE CAN'T SOLVE
THE PROBLEM BY FOCUSING ON
PLASTIC ALONE. WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON HOLISTIC SOLUTIONS FIRST
REDUCING WASTE AND THEN
INCREASED MANUFACTURE
RESPONSIBILITY WHEN IT COMES TO
THE MATERIALS THAT THEY'RE
BRINGING IT TO THE STATE. TO
MAKE SURE WHICH GENERATED CAN
BE MANAGED WITH IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. NEXT SLIDE. SO
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THIS CHART
PROCESS PRESENTATION BUT I'D
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT AN IMPORTANT
DATA POINT FROM THE SHARP.
PLASTIC IS MAKINGUP 11% OF OUR
DISPOSED WASTE STREAM IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. IN PLASTIC PACKAGING
AND PACKAGING RELATED MATERIAL
IN THE WASTE STREAM HAS
INCREASED SINCE TWENTY
FOURTEEN. BOTH THIS PROPORTION
OF ALL MATERIALS AND TOTAL
TONNAGE. THIS INCREASE IN
PLASTIC PACKAGING IS
SIGNIFICANT SINCE PLASTIC IS
VERY LIGHT IT MEANS THAT
GENERATION CONTINUES TO
INCREASE AT A RATE THAT DOESN'T
MATCH OUR ABILITY TO MANAGE.
NEXT SLIDE. THIS GRAPH SHOWS
THE PERCENTAGE OF MATERIAL ALL
MATERIALS RECYCLED FROM TWENTY
TEN TO TWENTY NINETEEN SO THIS
INCLUDES ON PLASTIC PAPER
METALS FEDERA RECYCLING HAS
BEEN DECREASING SINCE TWENTY
FOURTEEN WHERE IT WAS AT AN ALL
TIME HIGH OF 50% IN CALIFORNIA
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY NINE SPURRED
INVESTMENT IN STRONG COLLECTION
AND SORTING INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
MASTER PROCESSING IS PRETTY
GOOD FOR SOME MATERIALS LIKE P.
T. NH TP BUT WEEK FOR OTHERS
LIKE NEXT THREE THREE SEVEN
PLASTICS WE TRADITIONALLY
RELIED ON EXPORTS RECYCLING OF
THOSE MATERIALS. IN CALIFORNIA
WE COUNT EXPORTED RECYCLABLES
AS RECYCLED FOR THE PURPOSE OF
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY NINE AND
ALSO FOR WHEN WE ON CALCULATOR
RECYCLING RIGHT. EXPORTED
FRACTION OF OUR WASTE STREAM
HAS HISTORICALLY ACCOUNTED FOR
UP TO A THIRD OF ALL MATERIALS
RECYCLED IN CALIFORNIA. WE CAN
NO LONGER RELIANT EXPORTS
REASONS I'LL GET INTO IN A FEW
SLIDES AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO
INCREASE GENERATION OF
INCREASINGLY COMPLEX PRODUCTS
AND PACKAGING. WITHOUT
CORRESPONDING RECYCLING
SOLUTIONS. NEXT SLIDE. AS
MENTIONED CALIFORNIA HAS ROBUST
COLLECTION SORTING
INFRASTRUCTURE IS JOHN JUST
DISCUSSED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
JURISDICTIONS. AND INDUSTRY
HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN THE STOCK
INFRASTRUCTURE AND REMOVING
RECYCLABLES THAT HAVE MARKET.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE FOCUSED
ON REDUCING WASTE REDUCING
CONTAMINATION INCREASING
DIVERSION OF MATERIALS IN THE
WASTE STREAM. HOWEVER IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
TO KEEP PACE WITH THE
COMPLEXITYOF PRODUCTS AND
PACKAGING ENTERING CALIFORNIA
MARKET ESPECIALLY PLASTIC
PRODUCTS. NEXT SLIDE. MARKETS
FOR RECYCLED PLASTICS HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY THE
INTRODUCTION OF STRICTER
INTERNATIONAL POLICIES
REGARDING IMPORT OF SCRAP OR
RECYCLED MATERIAL. THESE
INTERNATIONAL POLICIES ARE A
GOOD THING. THANKS TO ENSURE
THAT THE COUNTRIES WITH A
PROVIDE UPON TO IMPORT OUR
RECYCLABLES ARE NOT IMPORTING
OUR GARBAGE WITH THOSE
RECYCLABLES. MUCH OF WHAT WE
ARE EXPORTING TO FOREIGN
COUNTRIES WERE MATERIALS LIKE
LOW VALUE THREE THREE SEVEN
PLASTICS THAT DID NOT HAVE A
MARKET DOMESTICALLY. WE HAVE NO
WAY OF TRACKING IT AND HOW
THOSE MATERIALS ARE RECYCLED.
AND THEREFORE NO WAY KNOWING IF
THEY'RE CONTRIBUTING TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH OR SOCIAL
CHALLENGES IN OTHER. CHINA HAS
AN IMPENDING BAN ON ALL SOLID
WASTE IMPORTS. AND CURRENTLY.
INCLUDED IN THAT DEFINITION OF
SOLID WASTE IS RECYCLED IS
RECYCLABLE MATERIAL. CHINA WAS
THE FIRST COUNTRY TO INTRODUCE
RESTRICTIVE IMPORT POLICIES AND
HAVE BEEN TIGHTENING THOSE
POLICIES YEAR AFTER YEAR. MOST
OF THE REDUCTION IN EXPORTS
MATERIALS PARTICULARLY MIXED
PLASTICS WAS DUE TO CHINA'S
POLICIES. WE'VE STILL BEEN ABLE
TO MOVE SOME MATERIAL TO CHINA
BUT THAT MIGHT BE CHANGING WITH
THIS IMPENDING BACK. SINCE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OTHER COUNTRIES
ON. MAINLY IN SOUTHEAST AND
SOUTH ASIA HAVE INTRODUCED
SIMILAR POLICIES TO CHINA'S
POLICIES. AND OF THE LAST MAJOR
IMPENDING CHANGES THE BASEL
CONVENTION AMENDMENTS ON MIXED
PLASTICS PLEASE TAKE THESE TAKE
PLACE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY ONES
WHICH IS RIGHT AROUND THE
CORNER. THE DALLAS THE
CONVENTION IS A MULTILATERAL
ENVIRONMENTAL AGREEMENT IN TO
PROTECT HUMAN HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT AGAINST THE ADVERSE
EFFECTS OF WASTE. THE GROUP OF
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE SIGNED ON
VOTED TO PLACE NEW RESTRICTIONS
ON SCRAP PLASTICS PRIMARILY
AFFECTING MIXED PLASTICS. WHAT
THIS MEANS IS THAT ALLOWABLE
PLASTICS CAN ONLY BE EXPORTED
WHEN BOTH PARTIES HAVE GIVEN
WRITTEN CONSENT. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THE US HAS NEVER
RATIFIED THE CONVENTION. THE
OTHER PARTY COUNTRIES ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO TRADE WITH NON PARTY
COUNTRIES EXCEPT UNDER
BILATERAL OR MULTILATERAL
AGREEMENTS. SO WHAT DO THESE
POLICIES MEAN. THERE ARE LESS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIA TO
EXPORT RECYCLABLES. ESPECIALLY
THOSE LIKE MIXED PLASTICS THAT
HAVE QUESTIONABLE INTERNATIONAL
MARKETS. THIS PROVIDES BOTH
WITH THE CHALLENGE AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REDUCE THESE
MATERIALS. AND PROCESS MORE
MATERIALS DOMESTICALLY NEXT
SLIDE. AS MENTIONED THERE'S
BEEN A SIGNIFICANT DECREASE IN
BOTH EXPORTS OF HIGHER VALUE
PLASTICS LIKE PT IN HD THAT'S
THE FIRST CHART ON THE LEFT AS
WELL AS LOWER VALLEY MIXED
PLASTICS. AND THAT'S THE CHART
ON THE RIGHT. THESE DECREASES
ARE A DIRECT RESULT OF THE
POLICIES ARE DISCUSSED IN THE
PREVIOUS SLIDE. ALL RIGHT NEXT
SLIDE. KARAKUL HAS A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS FOCUSED ON PLASTICS
ROSS DISCUSSED A FEW OF OUR KEY
PROGRAMS LISTED HERE AND
ALTHOUGH THESE PROGRAMS ARE
IMPORTANT FOR REDUCING PLASTIC
WASTE THE ONLY ADDRESS A NARROW
PORTION OF THE PLASTICS
GENERATED IN CALIFORNIA. NEXT
SLIDE. SO NOW THA THESE
PLASTICS ARE STAYING IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SOME
CHALLENGES TO OVERCOME TO
RESPONSIBLY MANAGE THEM HERE.
FIRST CHALLENGES THAT THERE'S
NO CONNECTION BETWEEN WHAT IS
GENERATED IN CALIFORNIA WHAT IS
ACTUALLY BEING RECYCLED IN THE
STATE. IT'S BECOME INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT AND COSTLY TO
EFFECTIVELY SORT THE MERIT OF
PLASTICS. AND PLASTICS PRODUCTS
AND PACKAGING THAT ENTER THE
RECYCLING SYSTEM. PLASTIC
MATERIAL QUALITIES INCONSISTENT
COLLECTED CONTAMINATION IS AN
ISSUE. BUT SO IS THE SHEER
VARIETY OF MATERIALS. IN
PRODUCTS SOMETIMES RECYCLERS
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH OF THIS TO
SPECIFIC MATERIAL TO COLLECTOR
BALAK MATERIAL. ANOTHER
CHALLENGES AS OIL PRICES ARE
LOW VIRGIN PLASTIC IS MUCH
CHEAPER THAN RECYCLE PLASTIC
DRIVING DOWN SCRAP VALUE OF
RECYCLED PLASTIC. WITH THE NEW
GLOBAL REQUIREMENTS REGARDING
PLASTICS LIKE THE BALLOT THE
CONVENTION CALIFORNIA WILL NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO RELY. ON
EXPORTS FOR RECYCLING. IT'S
OFTEN DIFFICULT TO MANAGE WHAT
IS THE MEASURE ADDITIONAL
AUTHORITY WOULD BE NEEDED FOR
CAL RECYCLE TO COLLECT
ADDITIONAL DATA ON THE
GENERATION OF PLASTIC. NEXT
SLIDE. SO WHAT ARE THE
SOLUTIONS THE FIRST IS ALWAYS
THE FIRST PART REDUCE.
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN WHICH
GENERATION MEANS MORE STUFF TO
MANAGE NEED TO WORKTOGETHER TO
IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES TO
REDUCE PLASTIC PRODUCTS AND
PACKAGING. WASTE ALSO CAN BE
REDUCED YOUR PRODUCT AND
PACKAGING DESIGN NOT ONLY
THROUGH SOURCE REDUCTION BUT
ALSO TO ENSURE WHAT IS BEING
GENERATED CAN BE MANAGED TO OUR
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
SECOND OPTION IS THE SECOND ARE
REDUCE THIS YEAR POWER CYCLE IS
PILOTING A REDUCE GRANT PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION COVERED NINETEEN
HAS IMPACTED REUSABLE
ALTERNATIVES TO DISPOSABLE
PLASTIC PRODUCTS AND PACKAGING
STATEWIDE. WE ARE STILL WASTING
THIS TREND REVERSES PUBLIC
HEALTH DATA IS SHOWING US HOW
REUSABLE CAN BE SAFELY USED.
NEXT WE NEED TO OPTIMIZE EXPAND
INFRASTRUCTURE KEEP MATERIALS
CLEAN CONTAMINATION CURBSIDE
CREATES A CHALLENGE FOR
DEVELOPING CLEAN BILLS OF
MATERIAL LOW CONTAMINATION IS
CRITICAL FOR RECYCLED MATERIAL
TO BE MANUFACTURED INTO NEW
PRODUCTS. HELLO CYCLES
LAUNCHING A STATEWIDE PUBLIC
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN TO HELP
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ON RECYCLING
RATE REDUCING CONTAMINATION.
ANDREA HAD MENTIONED THAT
BETTER EDUCATION ABOUT
RECYCLING RIGHT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND THAT INCLUDES
BEING HONEST ABOUT WHAT ISN'T
ACTUALLY RECYCLABLE. CHANGING
INTERNATIONAL POLICIES
INCREASING SINGLE USE
DISPOSABLE PACKAGING PRODUCTS
DEMONSTRATES THIS NEED FOR MORE
IN STATE PROCESSING. DEVELOPING
ROBUST RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE
IN CALIFORNIA TO CREATE JOBS
AND REDUCE CLIMATE IMPACTS
MOVING US TOWARDS MORE OF A
CIRCULAR ECONOMY. FOR
RECYCLABLES THAT WE'RE STILL
EXPORTING IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE DO IT RESPONSIBLY. POLICY
HAS A ROLE IN SPRING MARKET
DEVELOPMENT IN REDUCING PLASTIC
WASTE TWO EXAMPLES OF THE
PLASTIC MARKET DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM A MINIMUM RECYCLED
CONTENT. A PLASTIC MARKET
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM PROVIDES
MARKET INCENTIVES FOR PLASTIC
RECYCLING THIS PROGRAM HAS TEN
MILLION IN FUNDING TO SUPPORT
PROCLAIMERS AND REMANUFACTURES
FOR THE CLEANING IF USED TO
RECYCLE PLASTIC IN CALIFORNIA.
IN EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY THREE
WHICH WAS JUST RECENTLY SIGNED
REQUIRES BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
BEVERAGE MANUFACTURERS TO USE
50% RECYCLED CONTENT IN PLASTIC
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS BY TWENTY
THIRTY. WILL HELP SUPPORT THE
MARKET FOR RECYCLED PLASTICS.
THIS RECYCLED CONTENT
REQUIREMENT IS THE HIGHEST IN
THE WORLD. NEXT SLIDE. SOME OF
WHAT'S AHEAD WILL HELP US GET
CLOSER TO A SOLUTION. THE
RECYCLING AND DISPOSAL
REPORTING SYSTEM WILL GIVE US A
BETTER PICTURE OF RECYCLABLE
MATERIAL FLOWS IN CALIFORNIA
BUT STILL WANT CAPTURE
GENERATION OF PLASTIC PRODUCTS
BEING SOLD INTO CALIFORNIA BUT
IT'LL HELP US BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S BEING RECYCLED HERE.
ORGANICS TO PROVISION TO SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WILL HELP
REMOVE CONTAMINATION FROM THE
PREVENT. R. S. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY FIVE RANKS WILL BE
FINALIZED BY THE END OF THE
YEAR. IN THESE RACKS WILL
DEFINE RECYCLABLE REUSABLE AND
COMPOSTABLE FOODSERVICE
PACKAGING IN STATE FACILITIES
IT'S THE FIRST TIME THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN GIVEN THE
AUTHORITY TO DEFINE THESE
TERMS. AND WE'RE FOCUSING ON
WHAT IS ACTUALLY RECYCLABLE AND
COMPOSTABLE IN THE STATE.
THERE'S POTENTIAL THAT THESE
DEFINITIONS COULD HAVE BROADER
APPLICABILITY IF WE SEE
PACKAGING LEGISLATION IN THE
FUTURE. THERE'S POTENTIAL FOR
LARGE SCALE REFORM. SO IN
CLOSING EXPANSION OF RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA IN
THE REGION. AS WELL AS
OPPORTUNITIES TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF PLASTIC WASTE WE
CREATE. WILL BE KEY IN REDUCING
THE IMPACT OF PLASTICS IN THE
FUTURE. HOWEVER BUILDING MORE
DOMESTIC INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT
SUFFICIENT BY ITSELF. MANY
PLASTIC PRODUCTS AND PACKAGING
CURRENTLY BEING SOLD IN THE
STATE DESPITE CLAIMS OF
RECYCLABLE AND REUSABLE- IN
COMPOSTABLE AREN'T REALITY NOT
COMPATIBLE WITH CALIFORNIA'S
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE YOU
CAN EVEN ACCESS CONTAMINANT WAS
LIKELY PROCESS. A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH IS
WHAT'S NEEDED ONE THAT REDUCES
WASTE LOOKS UPSTREAM THAT
PRODUCT DESIGN AND MANUFACTURE
RESPONSIBILITY AND SUPPORTS A
CIRCULAR ECONOMY TO REDUCE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GREENHOUSE GAS
IMPACTS THE PLASTIC GENERATION
MANAGING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE PRESENTATION I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU AND THEN I
THINK I'LL SEE IF MY-
COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR YOU AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE TO THE OTHER
PANELISTS. I MY QUESTION TO YOU
IS WHETHER THE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN CAL EPA
ACCORD NEED AT ALL ANY OF THEIR
EFFORTS TO TACKLE THE PLASTIC
POLLUTION THAT'S ALREADY IN THE
ENVIRONMENT GOING INTO THE
ENVIRONMENT PARTICULARLY THE
WASTE TREATMENT IN WATER WASTE.
AND I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S NEW EMERGING DATA ABOUT
AIRBORNE PLASTIC POLLUTION SO
MORNING IF YOU CAN TALK ABOUT
THAT AS WELL. YEAH STOURPORT
WITHIN THE KELLY K. FAMILY ON A
NUMBER OF THE ISSUES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE PLASTIC POLLUTION AND-
ALSO THE ON- OPC AS WELL AS ON
THEIR DEVELOPING. THAT LOOK
MORE. PLASTICS ARE SKIPPING
INTENT INTO THE ENVIRONMENT ON
IS FAR AS THE URBAN AND OF
CLASS ON. I NOT SURE BUT I
WOULD CHIU BECAUSE THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT EMERGING AREA IN
WHICH WE NEED TO FOCUS IN. ON
THANK YOU AND ALSO SEE IF ANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS. FOR
YOU BEFORE MOVED TO THE US TWO
PANEL. IS GARCIA. YES THAT.
THANK YOU I PAUL IF I'M A
LITTLE. BUT OFTEN HE SAID AT
THE TIME OF THE DAY SO FOR ME-
I HAD A QUESTION- EARLIER ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE I. THE MONEY
DOLLAR AT THAT WILL INDUSTRY IS.
HAS BEEN ON THE CAMPAIGN TO
CONVINCE US THAT WE CAN RECYCLE
WAY OUT OF PROBLEM I EVEN
THOUGH WE CAN'T- AND THE FACT
THAT IF WE KNOW THERE MOVING.
OF THEIR BUSINESS INTO
PRODUCING PETROCHEMICALS AND
PLASTICS A SET OF WHAT WE THINK
ABOUT THEM CONVENTIONALLY DO WE
KNOW IF THEY ARE ALSO INVESTING
IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE OF
THIS. YEAH THERE ARE SOME
INDUSTRY INITIATIVES RIGHT NOW.
WHERE THERE ARE INVESTMENTS IN
NON. IN MORE DOMESTIC RECYCLING
WITHIN THE UNITED STATES- I
DON'T KNOW THE- THE SCALE OF
THAT. AND I DON'T KNOW HOW
IMPACTFUL TO BE GIVEN THAT YOU
KNOW IS. THERE'S ONLY 9% OF
PLASTICS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
BEING RECYCLED GLOBALLY SO
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE SOME IN THIS
INVESTMENTS AND SOME ON
INDUSTRY. IT'S HARD TO KNOW.
HOW FAR THEY'LL GO IN MAKING
THIS. DENT IN THE CHALLENGES
WITH RECYCLING PLASTICS. AND
THEN WHEN YOU- AND TO BE THIS
NEED TO TALK ABOUT WE USED TO.
A LOT OF THIS MATERIAL FOR. AND
WE'RE NOT ANYMORE BUT WITH IT
BEING RECYCLING IT WAS BEING
EXPORTED. AND THAT'S THE
CHALLENGE WE JUST DON'T KNOW WE
KNOW THAT SOME OF IT WAS- BUT
WE DON'T KNOW THE EXTENT OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT- WHAT
WERE EXPORTING FAILS OF- SINGLE
MATERIALS TO LIKE ADJUSTED PTB
THAT'S RELATIVELY CLEAN OR JUST
EACH DETAIL. AND THAT'S
GENERALLY GETTING RECYCLED THE
CHALLENGES AND THE MIXED
PLASTIC BALES THOSE BALES OF
PLASTICS THREE THROUGH SEVEN
WORKS HARD TO SAY WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THOSE WE KNOW
THAT SOMETIMES PUBLIC PROBABLY
NUMBER FIVE IS PULLED OUT OF
THOSE. AND RECYCLED BUT SOME OF
THOSE OTHER PLASTICS WE JUST
DON'T KNOW. WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENS TO THEM ONCE THEY'RE
EXPORTED. COUNTRIES AND THEN
FINALLY I YOU'VE BEEN. TRACKING
MORE DATA. ON AND IN THIS. OUR
WE- DO WE HAVE ANY SORT OF LIKE
EQUITY TOOLS THAT WOULD HELP
PRIORITIZE COMMUNITIES OF
COLORS OR REAL COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE- ACTED IN AN DIFFERENT WAYS
IN INEXORABLY I TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS WE ARE. ALLOCATING
DOLLARS TO RESOURCES THAT WE
DID IT IN AN EQUITABLE WAY. HE
ALSO WON THE ALSO ARE RELY ON-
AND VIRUS FREE. S. ON A TOOL
FOR WEB WHERE ON AWARDING
ACROSS SO WE- GIVE OUR- GRANT
YOU THE OPERA HOUSE GAS WE
DON'T FUND FOR INTEREST IN THIS.
AND WE HAVE A FIBER PLASTIC IN
LAST GRANT WHICH- WE INVEST IN
IN. TO WORST THOSE- AND WE USE
COUNT SCREEN ON TO HELP US I
DON'T. YES AND WHICH TO. INVEST
THOSE THOSE- THOSE FRIENDS BUT
AS YOU GET MY- THERE ARE ON IN
BURMA JUSTICE CONCERN ABOUT
OFFICE SO IT'S PRETTY IMPORTANT
AS WERE THINKING ABOUT IF YOU
INTEREST OF CALIFORNIA IF WE
WANTED TO BUT STILL- DEVELOP
MORE DOMESTIC INFRASTRUCTURE
PROCESS RECYCLED. THAT WE'RE
DOING IN A WAY THAT WE HAVE AN
AND TO COMMUNITIES- AND RIGHT
NOW WE'RE USING SCREEN AS OUR
AS OUR SCREEN TOOL TO IDENTIFY
THOSE COMMUNITIES ARE AND I'M
MUCH OF THAT HAS TO DO WITH ON
THE LOCAL CITING OF THESE
FACILITIES TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE A ORDINATED APPROACH WHEN
THESE FACILITIES ARE GETTING
CITED. THANK YOU. MR MCCARTY.
SURE I HAVE TO GO. FOR CAL
RECYCLE. ONE ON THAT CHART THAT
YOU SHOWED ABOUT RECYCLING
RATES THE LAST TEN YEARS OR SO.
I DON'T. WELL FIRST OF ALL
THANKS FOR THE PRESENTATION AND
NONE OF THIS NEWS IS THIS
UPLIFTING IS KIND OF YOU KNOW
DEPRESSING FROM ALL
PERSPECTIVES THE- ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT THE HEALTH IMPACT AND
THAT JUST THE PRACTICAL IMPACT
A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO FOUR SO.
THE FIRST QUESTION THIS PIECE
IS- IS THAT DO YOU FOLKS FROM
THE RESEARCH PERSPECTIVE THINK
WAS MORE AS- KIDS. MORE TOP
THERE WE'RE USING. OR THE
MARKET ISSUES THAT YOU KNOW
CHINA AND SO FORTH ARE NOT
TAKING- YOU KNOW THE- THE CONT
ESPECIALLY PLAST. AND OVERALL
RECYCLING IS A BIGGER PICTURE
TAX WE A HEARING ANOTHER THIS
WEEK WITH IS FOR CLASS IS THAT
IS ARE THEY EACH OR ONE MORE
THAN THE OTHER. YOUR A REALLY
GOOD QUESTION AND- I HAVE A OF
CHART THAT OFTEN SHOW
PRESENTATIONS THAT. THAT SO THE
RELAY. BETWEEN ON WAGES AND-
GENERATION OF THE- AND WHAT WE
SEE IS THAT WHEN THE ECONOMY IS
GOOD WE GENERATE MORE STUFF.
AND UP UNTIL PREVIOUSLY THE
ECONOMY HAVE BEEN REALLY GOOD
SO WE ARE GENERATING A LOT MORE
THINGS- ON. AND A LOT OF THESE
THINGS DIDN'T NECESSARILY HAVE.
PLACES FOR THEM TO GO TO GET
RECYCLED SO MUCH OF THAT WAS
DUE TO- THESE INTERNATIONAL
POLICIES BUT ALSO DUE TO JUST
THE SHEER AMOUNT OF THE SHEER
VOLUME OF MATERIAL GOING INTO
THE SYSTEM. AND THEN- BECAUSE
OF THE VOLUME THAT'S GOING INTO
THE BLUE BINS WE SEE A LOT OF
THIS CONTAMINATION. WHICH MAKES
THIS MATERIAL EVEN HARDER TO
RECYCLE SO I THINK TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION I WOULD SAY THAT
IT'S REALLY A COMBINATION OF
THESE THINGS. WE'RE GENERATING
LOT OF STUFF ON INTERNATIONAL
POLICIES ARE COMING DOWN AS-
THE INTERNATIONAL RECYCLING
COMMUNITY IS GETTING CLEANED UP
AND- WE'RE JUST SEEING THAT
TRANSLATE INTO. YOU KNOW THE
REALITY OF LOW RECYCLING RATES
AS WORK JUST GENERATING MORE
DISPOSING MORE. SO IT'S A BIG
CHALLENGE. THANK YOU AND SO
THAT LEADS. TO MY TO MY SECOND
QUESTION SO. SIR WE CAN TALK
ABOUT- MANUFACTURERS AND- THAT
ARE MAKING THE PACKAGING AND
THE- GOODS BUT IT'S ON US
BECAUSE WE'RE BUYING ALL THAT
STUFF SO IT'S A TWO PART
SOLUTION A TWO PART ISSUE
THEY'RE LOOKING I THINK THAT
THE PROBLEM. AND I WOULD ASSUME
THAT IF YOU HAD THE INDUSTRY
FOLKS IN HERE RIGHT BEFORE US
TODAY THEY WOULD UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S A BIG ISSUE- YOU KNOW
THAT. THAT THAT THERE IS A- NO
WIN SITUATION FOR THAT FOR THEM
RIGHT NOW AS WELL. I'M NOT
TRYING TO PUT THEM OFF THE HOOK
BUT- ARE ARE THERE ANY
REALISTIC- FRANK SIDES FAR AS-
YOU KNOW WHAT. AMAZON IS DOING
OR WHAT YOU KNOW INDUSTRY IS
DOING ON THE ON THE SINGLE USE
PLASTICS YOU KNOW WITH
DIFFERENT MATERIALS THAT ARE
COMPOSTABLE I KNOW YOU CAN. DO
WE CAN- SQUABBLE OVER WHAT THE
DEFINITION OF TRULY COMPOSTABLE
SO. THE OTHER IS THERE ANY YEAH
IT DOES SOLUTIONS ON ON THE
HORIZON THAT WE COULD HAVE ANY
OPTIMISM ABOUT THIS BESIDES
LOOKING AT OUR- DEMAND
PERSPECTIVE. YEAH IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION AND- CAL RECYCLE NEED
WITH INDUSTRY PARTNERS ALL THE
TIME AND THERE'S A LOT OF. US
ON REALLY GREAT AFTER COMING
FROM INDUSTRY FROM RECYCLED
CONTENT GOALS TO ACTUAL
RECYCLABILITY GOALS AND- YOU
KNOW PACKAGING DESIGNERS AND
PRODUCT DESIGNERS THAT ARE
THINKING MORE ABOUT END OF LIFE
PRODUCTS. BUT AS WE'RE SEEING
FROM THE DATA THAT THAT I'VE
SHOWN THAT RUSH HAS SHOWN THE
NUMBER THE OTHER SPEAKERS.
SHOWN IS THAT WE'RE JUST NOT
SEEING THE NEEDLE MOVE YET SO-
THESE ARE ALL GREAT AMBITIOUS
GOALS BUT WE REALLY NEED THE
ROBERT HALF THE ROAD. TO
REALIZE THAT THE CHANGES THAT
COULD BE ACCOMPANIED WITH THOSE
AND- YOU KNOW I DON'T I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE'LL GET THERE BY
INDUSTRY INITIATIVES ALONE IT
SEEMS SUPPORTIVE POLICIES GOING
TO BE. VERY VERY IMPORTANT FOR
HELPING US. REACH THE GOALS
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
EXAMPLE BY TWENTY TWENTY WE
WERE SUPPOSED TO PER EIGHTY
THREE FORTY ONE RECYCLE 75% OF
ALL MATERIAL WE'RE GENERATING
IN THE STATE AND- AT 37% AND
TWENTY NINETEEN WERE FAR FROM
THAT SO. IT'S GOING TO TAKE-
COMMITMENT BY INDUSTRY- AS WELL
AS SUPPORT OF POLICIES FOR US
TO REALLY. GET TO WHERE WE WANT
TO GO BUT YES INDUSTRIES DOING
QUITE A BIT YEAH I GUESS WHAT
I'M LOOKING AT IS THAT WELL
FIRST OF ALL. I DON'T- SUPPORT
THE NOTION THAT WE CAN LIVE
IT'S ALL INDUSTRY THEY'RE GOING
TO SOLVE THIS WILL SOLVE THE
PROBLEM I THINK. TWENTY THIRTY
YEARS AGO AS WE SAID EARLIER
THEY SET UP. JUST RECYCLE
EVERYTHING'S GOOD POINT THEY A
BLUE PANTS UP THAT'S NOT
WORKING SO CLEARLY WE HAVE A
WALL. AND FEDERAL POLICY AND
STATE POLICY BUT I GUESS I
GUESS I'M WHAT I'M WHAT I'M
WONDERING IS. YOU KNOW ARE
THERE IT SEEMS THAT SOMEBODY IF
THEY CAME UP WITH THE PRODUCTS
AND I MENTIONED THIS THE OTHER
DAY AND I'M I'M NOT SURE IF
IT'S ACCURATE BUT YOU KNOW
PEOPLE WHO ARE PUTTING PEOPLE
TO THE- TO THE- YOU KNOW. HAD A
SPACER. ON ALL THE TECHNOLOGY
WE HAVE YOU THINK THAT SOMEBODY
WOULD COME UP WITH SOME.
BIODEGRADABLE PRODUCT AND THEY
COULD JUST. MAKE OUT YOU KNOW
TURN ON THE UPSIDE ECONOMIC OF
THAT SO. IS THERE ANYTHING I
THERE IN THE- THAT HAS AN
ALTERNATIVE. TO PLASTIC THAT WE
THINK IS A- IT'S HARD QUESTION
TO ANSWER GIVE ON. THE AMOUNT
OF DIFFERENT. THAT ARE BEING
INTRODUCED RIGHT NOW SO ON YOU
KNOW SOME INDUSTRY INITIATIVES
ARE MOVING FROM PLASTIC TO
FIBER. BUT THERE'S CHALLENGES
WITH THE FIBER RECYCLING MARKET
TO- YOU KNOW COMPOSED ABILITY
IN FACT WOULD DEGRADE ABILITY.
ARE ARE CHALLENGING IN HOW THEY
ACTUALLY BEHAVE IN THESE
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENTS AND IF
THEY'RE SORTED CORRECTLY AND
ARE WASTE INFRASTRUCTURE SO ALL
THAT TO SAY IS THAT- INNOVATION
IS HAPPENING AND IT'S EXCITING
BUT- THERE ISN'T A SILVER
BULLET TO GET US THERE I MEAN
REALLY WHERE WE NEED TO FOCUS
IS ON. WASTE REDUCTION AND THEN
IDENTIFYING WITH INNOVATION HOW
THAT FITS INTO OUR EXISTING
SYSTEM OR IF THERE ARE GOING TO
BE NEW SYSTEMS WHAT BEHAVIOR
CHANGE LOOKS LIKE ON THE
CONSUMER SIDE. TO MAKE SURE
THOSE GET MATERIALS ARE GOING
TO THE RIGHT PLACE BECAUSE THEY
WON'T BEHAVE CREEK CRACKLY IN
OUR SYSTEMS. IF THEY'RE GOING
TO THE WRONG PLACE SO FOR
EXAMPLE YOU KNOW COMBUSTIBLE
PLASTICS ARE ARE INNOVATIVE AND
EXCITING BUT IF THEY'RE NOT
ACTUALLY. GOING TO COMPOST AND
WILL THEY CONTAMINATE PLASTIC
RECYCLING STREAM SO IT'S- IT'S
A SYSTEMATIC- CHALLENGE BUT I
THINK THAT- WE CAN DO A BETTER
JOB OF HARMONIZING. THESE.
MATERIALS THAT ARE COMING IN
WITH. I MERGING TECH. TO US
THERE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR- BOTH- MR KENNEDY
AND MR AND MS- CONVALESCE AND
EITHER ONE OR BOTH OR NEITHER
OF YOU ARE WELCOME TO ANSWER
THESE ARE KIND OF JUST. KIND OF
THROWN OUT THERE FOR YOU- THE
FIRST ONE HAS TO DO WITH THE
MONETARY IMPACTS OF DEALING
WITH PLASTIC POLLUTION ON
LOCALITIES AND ON COUNTIES. AND
I KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT IN EACH COUNTY. BUT
DO YOU HAVE ANY GENERAL IDEAS
OF WHAT THE FINANCIAL IMPACT IS
ON. MUNICIPALITIES AND HOW THEY
PAY FOR IT HOW DO THEY DEAL
WITH THOSE IMPACTS. WHOEVER HE
WANTS TO JUST TO START. OR NOT
IT'S FINE TO. I MEAN ALL ALL
TAKE A FIRST STAB-
UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION TODAY SO I CAN TRY
AND DO SOME RESEARCH- I GOT
SOME ANECDOTAL INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW WE'RE HELPING TO
FACILITATE SOME OF THE ORGANIC-
GRASSROOTS CLEAN UP EFFORTS
THAT EXIST OUT THERE AND SOME
OF OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES- WE'RE
SEEING IT FOR JUST NORMAL LATER
ONE OF THE ENCOURAGING THINGS
WAS I. I HEARD ABOUT IT- FOR
RECREATIONAL FISHERS AS WELL
WHERE FISHING LINES ARE OUT
THERE IN THE ENVIRONMENT AND
WATERWAYS- AND THEY'RE BEING
TAKEN CARE OF BY FISHERS OUT
THERE TOO SO I CAN GO BACK AND
TRY AND FIND OUT HOW MUCH WE'RE
DEVOTING TO THOSE I KNOW WE DO
RECEIVE SOME- VERY VERY VERY
MODEST FUNDING FROM THE STATE
THROUGH VARIOUS PROGRAMS. TO
HELP FACILITATE SOME OF THOSE
GOALS BUT IT'S NOWHERE NEAR
WHAT'S NECESSARY FOR THOSE
OBJECTIVES RIGHT AND THERE'S
THE COSTS OF LITTER THEN
THERE'S ALSO THE COST OF THE
LANDFILLS THEMSELVES SURE RIGHT
AND I CAN GET MORE INFORMATION
ON THAT AS WELL I MEAN ALL
THOSE COSTS ARE BASICALLY
PASSED ON TO RATEPAYERS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES- EITHER THROUGH THE
GATE FEES OR- YOU KNOW THERE
ARE VERY BILLING MECHANISMS
THAT ARE USED IN THE TOURISTIC.
RIGHT BECAUSE SOMETIMES
SOMETHING HEAR FROM. QUITE A
BIT YEAH GONNA I'M GONNA GO TO
THIS- MISS AND- OF THE THAT.
YOU KNOW IF FOR THEIR REGULATED
MORE HIGHLY THERE ASK TO SWITCH.
A MORE EXPENSIVE MATERIAL OR TO
DO MORE STEWARDSHIP THAT
THEY'LL BE COSTS THAT ARE
PASSED ALONG TO CONSUMERS. AS
THOUGH THEY'RE NOT ALREADY
BEARING THOSE COSTS IN THE CASE
OF CONSUMERS THEY HAVE THE
CHOICE. OF WHETHER TO BUY A
PRODUCT OR NOT. BUT WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT COSTS THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO DEAL WITH THE
MEDICATION TO DEAL WITH THAT.
THE POLLUTION CLEAN UP THE
LANDFILLS THAT SPREAD ACROSS
EVERY SINGLE RESIDENT OF A
COMMUNITY WHETHER THEY BUY
PLASTIC PRODUCTS ARE NOT. SO
WHAT ABOUT THE CASE OF L. A.
COUNTY WHAT DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
THOSE COSTS ARE AND ARE THEY
INCREASING OR DECREASING AND
HOW MUCH OR- HOW MUCH IS AN
ORDINARY PERSON PAYING TOWARDS
THIS PROBLEM. YES ALL ALL THAT
JUST KIND OF ECHO I DON'T HAVE
EXACT NUMBERS ANY BE HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP TO FIND SOME MORE
SPECIFICS- I THINK. YOU KNOW I
CITED ONE STUDY THAT SHOWED-
IMPACTS ON THE ORDER OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR SAN
DIEGO AND I THINK THAT'S VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE'RE SEEING
ESPECIALLY FOR SOME OF OUR
LARGER CITIES IN THE COUNTY-
THAT BUT YOU KNOW IT IS. IT'S A
RELATIVELY NEW ISSUE WHEN IT'S
IN FLUX SO I THINK WE'RE STILL
KIND OF WAITING TO SEE EXACTLY
WHAT THE IMPACTS ARE GOING TO
BE AND ON REPAIRS I WOULD JUST
ECHO THAT. YOU KNOW WE DON'T
HAVE ANOTHER SOURCE OF FUNDING
ASIDE FROM- EITHER THE
JURISDICTION OR THE RATE PAYERS
AT THIS POINT SO THOSE WILL
FALL ON. RESIDENTS ULTIMATELY
WHAT MIGHT I SUGGEST THAT. AS
YOU DO YOUR UTILITY BILLS AND
YOU HAVE YOUR FEES. BUT IF YOU
FOUND A WAY TO SPIT OUT. A
PLASTIC DISPOSAL MITIGATION FEE
ON THAT BILL. THAT THERE MIGHT
BE ANOTHER REASON WHY RESIDENTS
WOULD SEE THE IMPORTANCE OF
GETTING THIS UNDER CONTROL. AND
TRULY UNDERSTAND. THE COSTS OF
THOSE CHEAP. DOLLAR STORE. TOYS
IN PRAGUE. THAT ARE SINGLE USE
OR THAT ARE CEAPLY MADE AND-
BECOME ESSENTIALLY SINGLE USE.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A HUGE COST-
DOWN THE ROAD TO THOSE VERY
SAME PEOPLE MANY OF WHOM CAN
NOT AFFORD IT STILL BE GREAT
JUST FIND A WAY TO. PARSE THAT
OUT. ON A BILL SOMEWHERE MAYBE
THAT'S AN IDEA FOR LEGISLATION.
AND IT MIGHT MY NEXT QUESTION
IS- I KNOW THAT YOU CAN'T SPEAK
FOR ALL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BUT
WHAT- WHAT ACTIONS THAT YOU'VE-
BEEN ABLE TO TAKE HAVE BEEN THE
MOST AFFECTED- IF ANY IN
DEALING WITH THESE ISSUES. AND
IF THE ANSWER IS NO NO YOU
DON'T KNOW THAT'S FINE TOO YEAH
JUST JUST GO AHEAD. I MEAN
ECHOING WHAT OTHERS HAVE SAID
AND I WENT IS SO WE FROM
CALORIE CYCLE THAT I DON'T
THINK ANYBODY'S. YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY FOUND THE SOLUTION TO
THE ISSUES- I JUST ECHO AGAIN
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE HAD ENORMOUS SUCCESS WITH
WAS THE PLASTIC BAG BAN- AND
THAT WAS- SORT OF A COMBINATION
OF POLICY DRIVING. BEHAVIOR
CHANGE WHICH AND DISH AND HAS-
YOU KNOW DRIVEN- INDUSTRY TO
SORT OF ADJUST SO- THAT WAS
INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL I THINK
THERE WAS THE FIRST YEAR AFTER
THAT WAS PASSED. THERE WAS
SOMETHING LIKE OVER 90%
REDUCTION IN- OBSERVE A LITTER
OF PLASTIC BAGS SO- I THINK IT
DOES SHOW THAT POLICIES AIMED
AROUND SOURCE REDUCTION- CAN
REALLY. CAN REALLY- IMPACT
THESE THINGS. AND ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES THAT YOU
HAVE WHEN YOU TRY TO ENACT
POLICIES LIKE PLASTIC BAG BAN
OR ANY OTHER POLICIES THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT. THIS IS FOR
EITHER OF YOU. WELL I'D LIKE TO
STEP BACK JUST A COUPLE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU ASK- THE SO.
WITH YOUR YOUR PROMPT ABOUT-
PUTTING A FEE ON RESIDENTS OF
BILLS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT TO
SHOW THE COST OF RECYCLING I
KNOW THERE ARE SOME
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE STARTED
DOING THAT- SOME JURISDICTIONS
AS THE RENEGOTIATING THEIR
FRANCHISE AGREEMENTS- THERE
COST. INCREASES ASSOCIATED WITH
NATIONAL SWORD. WE'RE RECYCLING
IS L. A. COUNTY AND POWER CYCLE
POINTED OUT USED TO BRING IN
MONIES TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-
NOW IT'S QUITE THE OPPOSITE AND
SO WE'RE ACTUALLY HAVING TO
SUBSIDIZE THOSE EFFORTS TO THE
RATEPAYERS. SO WE'RE SEEING
MORE ON BILL. FLAGS THAT THAT
EXISTS- AND RECYCLING FEES ARE
BEING IMPOSED- FOR SOME MORE
DIFFICULT TO MANAGE PRODUCTS WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A HIGHER GATE
FEES FOR THOSE MATERIALS- OR
TIPPING FEE- AND- AS FAR AS-
YOU KNOW. WHAT WORKS WE WERE
REALLY HOPEFUL FOR LAST YEAR'S
SOLUTION SB THIRTY FOUR EIGHTY
TEN EIGHTY- TO CREATE. SHE
PARTNER WITH ME FOR. SO THAT WE
CAN REALLY HAVE EVERYONE HAVING
TO SIT AT THE TABLE TO DEAL
WITH PLASTIC WASTE AND
RECYCLING. AND RECYCLABILITY
ESPECIALLY. THANK THANK YOU CAL
DO YOU HAVE ANY COME AOUT
BARRIERS TO HAVE OR AND I PAUL.
YEAH I MEAN IT JUST AGAIN
LOOKING AT SORT OF THE FOOD
SERVICE WARE ORDINANCE I ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CONCERNS ARE THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS- SO IT'S HI
THERE THERE IS JUST AND THERE
IS STILL- A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT WHAT THE IMPACT WILL BE
AND- EVEN THOUGH WE HAVEN'T
REALLY SEEN ANY- NEGATIVE
IMPACTS- FROM- AND THE
EXPERIENCE OF OTHER
JURISDICTIONS BUT THAT'S
CERTAINLY ONE OF THE BIGGEST
OBSTACLES- AND- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY WE HAVE. WE
DEFINITELY GET PUSHBACK FROM
THE INDUSTRY AS WELL- I'M
LOOKING AT THESE THINGS VERY
SIMILAR AG COMMENTS THAT YOU
THAT YOU HAVE- STATED IN TERMS
OF- THAT COSTS AND HOW THOSE
COSTS WILL IMPACT CONSUMERS AS
WELL- LIKE I MENTIONED THE
STUDY THAT WE HAD UCLA DID
REALLY KIND OF- YOU KNOW TOOK
APART SOME OF THOSE ARGUMENTS
AND MADE US FEEL THAT THEY WERE
AND- WE'RE TO ISSUE AND ALSO
HIGHLIGHTED THE FACT THAT AGAIN
AS YOU MENTIONED- CHIU FRIEDMAN
THAT- THESE COSTS ARE BEING
BORNE BY SOMEONE- IT'S MAYBE
NOT AS OBVIOUS TO EVERYBODY-
BUT BUT THEY STILL EXIST YOU
CAN AVOID THAT SO- BUT YES OF
COURSE PEOPLE ARE INCREDIBLY
CONCERNED ABOUT- COST TO
CONSUMERS AND BUSINESSES. AND
MY LAST QUESTION IS A LOT OF
TIMES THE STATE COMES IN AND
SORT OF PREAMPS THE LOCALS BY
MAYBE DOING A STATEWIDE PLASTIC
BAG BAN OR OTHER TYPE POLICIES
THAT MAYBE RESTRICT OR OVERRIDE
SOME OF THE LOCAL REGULATIONS-
IS THAT IS THAT HELPFUL OR IS
IT WOULD YOU RATHER THAT WE
COMPLETELY STAY OUT OF THE
TRASH BUSINESS OR IS IT HELP
WHEN WE COME IN AND TRY TO DO-
MORE REGULATIONS ON INDUSTRY
OR- I'M WE DISPARITIES I KNOW
THAT'S A REALLY BROAD QUESTIONS
MAYBE YOU CAN JUST GIVE SOME
EXAMPLES OF WHEN IT'S HELPED
WHEN IT'S HURT THAT KIND OF
THING. AND BY THE WAY HELPED
HER DEAL WITH THE PROBLEM YOU.
KNOW A PLASTICS UNDERGOING.
CONTROL COSTS- THAT KIND OF
THING. I MEAN WHEN YOU HAVE
SOME LIKE A BOTTLE. I THINK
IT'S THE TO HELP THE THIS IS
THE ARE THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE
THE SMALL SCALE THE LOCAL LEVEL-
IT HELPS TO A MARKET FOR THOSE
MATERIALS AND GETTING. OUT
THERE- AT THE SAME TIME I KNOW
A LOT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
STRONGLY BRISTLED AT THE NOTION
OF PREEMPTION- AND RESTRICTING
THE ABILITY FOR LOCALS TO COME
IN AND ADOPT ORDINANCES THAT
MAY BE MORE RESTRICTIVE BEFORE
DIFFERENT AND WE ACTUALLY HAD
SOME CHALLENGES THIS LAST YEAR
WITH- WORKED THIS YEAR. WITH
CODED IN THE PLASTIC BAG BANS-
BECAUSE THERE WAS A DIFFERENT
TREATMENT AMONG BE
GRANDFATHERED- MUNICIPALITIES
THAN AMONG THOSE MUNICIPALITIES
THAT WERE GRANDFATHERED IN THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER- AND IT WAS
DIFFICULT FOR LOCALS. TO
GRAPPLE WITH. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE. YEAH GO AHEAD. MMHM OKAY-
YEAH I MEAN YOU KNOW OF COURSE
CALIFORNIA'S INCREDIBLY DIVERSE
STATE AND- L. A. COUNTY STATE
FACES VERY SPECIFIC ISSUES JUST
AS I AM AN EXTREMELY LARGE-
COUNTY- SO YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
GENERALLY NOT SUPPORTIVE OF
STRICT- PREEMPTION CLAUSE IS-
WE LIKE TO AT LEAST HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO- YOU KNOW DESIGN
SOLUTIONS THAT WORK FOR
COMMUNITIES- AT THE SAME TIME
THERE ARE WE ARE ALSO HIGHLY
SUPPORTIVE OF A LOT OF THESE
ISSUES BEING DEALT WITH ON A
STATE WIDE- ISSUE AS LONG AS
THEY ALLOW FOR SOME OF THAT
FLEXIBILITY- YOU KNOW THINGS
LIKE. OF COURSE JOHN MENTIONED
THE BOTTLE BILL THAT ALSO-
POLICIES LIKE AND- YOU KNOW IF
YOU ARE A PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY- AS WELL AS-
LOOKING AT THESE ISSUES THAT
LIKE SB FIFTY FOUR IN TEN
EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY WE'RE GOING
TO DEAL WITH- LOOKING AT
PACKAGING LIMITATIONS AND
MATERIAL DESIGN ARE REALLY
THINGS THAT WE CAN'T. DEAL WITH
ON A LOCAL LEVEL AND THAT ARE
REALLY BETTER I DEALT WITH ON A
STATEWIDE LEVEL- WHERE YOU KNOW
WE CAN WE CAN SORT OF COME UP
WITH THE JOINT SOLUTION AND-
HAVE ENOUGH OF A AT THAT
ECONOMY OF SCALE WHERE- THAT
IMPACT REALLY REALLY MAKES A
DIFFERENCE SO- YES WE'RE WE'RE
DEFINITELY SUPPORTIVE OF SOME
OF THESE ISSUES HAPPENING ON- A
STATE WIDE LEVEL THANK YOU
THAT'S THE ONLY QUESTIONS I
HAVE MS GARCIA ANY QUESTIONS. I
WANT TO THANK BOTH OF OUR
PANELISTS ACTUALLY ALL THREE OF
OUR PANELISTS AND ALLTHE
PANELS THAT WE HAD TODAY THIS
WAS VERY VERY HELPFUL AND WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO
PUBLIC- COMMENT IF THERE'S
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO- TO COMMENT- THERE'S
TWO MINUTES A PERSON ANYBODY.
OKAY THEN WE'LL GO TO ANYBODY
WHO WANTS TO PARTICIPATE BY
PHONE A MODERATOR IF YOU CAN
QUEUE UP THROUGH THE SPEAKERS
AND. BRING THE FIRST SPEAKER IN.
THANK TWO MINUTES OF. OPERATOR
ARE YOU THERE AND- YES YOU HEAR
ME YES I CAN THANK YOU OKAY.
AND WE NEED TO ABOUT THREE AND
QUEUE BE A MALL. AND AGAIN A
ONE THEN. IF YOU HAVE A COMMON.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO BE A
DISTRICT MAINTAINING THE TO.
RULE. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
FOR OPERATE. THANK AND THAT'S
THE ONE THEN THERE'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT FOR HER FIRST Vì AFTER
IN THE QUEUE JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE. BECAUSE WE KNOW. AND
WILL FIRST GO LINE NUMBER THREE
CALL. I NEED TO THREE YEAR OF
THE- YOU MAY BE NEEDED AT EACH.
KEPLINGER FREEMEN CHEN
REGARDING MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
COMMITTEE OUT OF REGULAR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE- WE HEARD A LOT TODAY
ABOUT THE NEGATIVE IMPACT OF
PLASTIC POLLUTION TO OUR
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT AS WELL TO
MAKE CLEAR CAL CHAMBER AND ITS
MEMBERS SHARE THE GOAL OF
REDUCING PLASTIC POLLUTION
INCREASING RECYCLING RATES AND
SOURCE REDUCING RAW MATERIAL.
TO THAT END I WANTED TO PROVIDE
SOME FEEDBACK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AS WE THINK ABOUT
HOW TO DEVELOP A STATE WIDE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY. BURKE I THINK
EVERYONE IN IN IT ISSUE. A THAT
POLITICS WILL. MUST BE. BEYOND
BORDERS TO TRULY AN AND- ON
POLLUTION IN THE MARINA. SECOND
I THINK MENU GET HIT A THAT- I
THINK IT'S REALLY AND- BUT WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT A STATE OF PRO OR
THE- PRO. IF CALIFORNIA IS WORK
TOWARDS CREATE OF THE STATE
WIDE CIRCULAR A- THERE NEEDS TO
BE MORE DISCUSSED ABOUT HOW TO
SPIN. THE STATE APPROACH TO
COMPLEMENT THE STATE WIDE
MANDATE. IT IS CRITICAL TO
PROVIDE INDUSTRY WITH THE
COMPLIANCE PATHWAY AT THE
CURRENT PATCHWORK OF RECYCLING
AND COMPOSTING REQUIREMENTS
ACROSS THE MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
CANNOT CO EXIST WITH A
STATEWIDE CIRCULAR. WITH
STATEWIDE MANDATE THE REGULATED
COMMUNITY CAN DESIGN FOR
STATEWIDE RECYCLABILITY
REQUIREMENTS BUT IT CANNOT
DESIGN AND INVEST IN A COUNTY
BY COUNTY APPROACH. SIMILARLY
AS NOTED EARLIER THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS ARE
CRITICAL TO MAKING THIS WORK.
AND WE AGREE THAT SHIPPING
MATERIALS OVERSEAS IS NOT A
POLLUTION. AND WE NEED TO
INVEST IN OUR CURRENT RECYCLING
AND COMPOSTING SYSTEM PROVIDE
WELL PAYING JOBS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT COMPANIES CANNOT
AND WILL NOT DO THAT BILLION
IT'S NECESSARY TO DO THAT. IF
THEY'RE NOT CLEAR ON WHAT THE
STATE WIDE REQUIREMENTS ARE
GOING TO BE IF JURISDICTION BY
JURISDICTION CAN DO DIFFERENT
THINGS. AND ALL ALL ALL LEAVE
IT HERE ON ONE POSITIVE NOTE
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY IT
KNOWLEDGE IS THERE'S A PARADIGM
SHIFT UNDER WAY TO BUILD A
BETTER RECYCLING AND COMPOST.
IN HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WE WANT
TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION AND
WE'RE WORKING- AS WE HAVE THE
LAST TWO YEARS TO REALLY WORK
ON INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS THAT
ACTUALLY BUILD OUT THE AND MARK
AND I'LL LEAVE IT THERE THINK
SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CALL- MODERATOR NEXT. COLOR
PLEASE. YES NOT TO A PHOTO TO
TWO PLEASE BY. THANK YOU HELLO
THANK YOU FOR A JOINT HEARING
ON SUPPORT MATTER MY NAME IS
CHRISTOPHER KANE NINETY YOUR
CAR CORE THANK YOU FOR WHERE
NEXT SEARCHING. WE HEARD FROM
OF NAY AND INTERNATIONALLY
RESPECTED ME ABOUT PROBLEMS
WITH PLASTIC POLLUTION WE KNOW
ENOUGH WE KNOW ENOUGH TODAY
ACTION AND WE NOT IS AN- ACT
NOW. YOU'RE GOING TO USE EVEN
MORE STARK WHEN WE GET THEIR
HOUSE PACKAGING KIND CRAZY HE A
LATE. PROBLEMS AT EVERY STAGE
OF THE LIFECYCLE PRACTICALLY
THE WELL HAD YOU DISPOSAL IN
THE KITCHEN MEYER. I THINK WE
CREATE THE MORE WE HAVE TO
DEAL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
ASKED HOW WE MIGHT DEAL WITH
THE FACT THAT WITHOUT THEIR-
HELLO EVENTUALLY HAVE TO DEAL
WITH BUT FOR NOW I THINK THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING IS TO
FOCUS ON TURNING OFF THE TAP.
IF OUR SINK IS OVERFLOWING OUR
FIRST INSTINCT IS NOT TO GRAB A
MOP OR TOWELS WE REACH FOR THE
FAUCET. THE PLASTIC AND PATRICK
INDUSTRY. ENCOURAGED GROUP ARE
WEEKS TO THINK BACK THE
INABILITY. BUT THAT IS THE WE
BOTH THE ON. WILL BE ABLE ONLY
HAVE TO WAIT MANAGEMENT AND
ACTUALLY THAT HAVE ON. ON JACK.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM HUMAN SOME
INDUSTRY MAY HAVE TO CHANGE
THEIR MUST CHANGE. AT SOME
POINT WE HAVE TO MAKING WE HAVE
TO MAKE A LEFT EIGHT EIGHT WE
HAVE TO STOP ME IT BACK THE-
NOW WITH THE- WE TO STOP.
SINGLE USE THAT ARE KILLING OUR
THANK LINE COMMUNITIES LEADER
OUR STREETS AND- OUR- AND
OCEANS. THE ONLY REFER TO THE
BALLOT MEASURE AND IN ON S.
CALIFORNIA. IF YOU PRACTICALLY
AND JERRY EFFECTS THE WORK
STAGE. LAST WEEK I PARTICIPATED
IN THE RIGHT. ADHOC EXPERTS WHO
WE ARE MIKE. AND THE GROUP OVER.
I WOULD HAVE ASK YOU. TO THE
PRODUCTION MATERIALS THAT ARE
NOT FUNCTIONALLY ANY FURTHER
CYCLE. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ENACT
THE LAW CAROLINE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS YEAH YOUR CRANE- PUBLIC
POLICY MANAGER FOR THE LIKE
TECHNOLOGIES AND- PRECIADO
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS REMAIN A CARD
THE CHAIRS ARE TAKING ARE
COMMON TODAY- WE ALSO SUBMITTED
A COMMENT- FOR THE RECORD-
THAT- ESSENTIALLY YOU KNOW
COLLEAGUES CONSIDER DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGY POLICY SOLUTIONS- WE
WOULD LOVE TO BE INVOLVED WITH
THE BUSINESS SIDE. OF THIS
COMMUNITY WITH THE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT ACTIVITIES ARE WE
ARE LAUNCHED OUR RESTORE- BRAND
COULD WEAR WHICH IS MADE FROM
AN ACTUAL MATERIAL AND WE WOULD
LOVE TO PROVIDE STAFFING
RESOURCE INFORMATION ON THE
VARIOUS ASPECTS OF A.
MANUFACTURING PROJECT ANALOGY-
YOU ALL WERE WELL AWARE THE
PROCTER CRISIS NOT JUST PAUL
BUT DAHLE LOOK EXCEL. GLOBAL
WARMING- AND THAT IS WHY WE ARE
TRYING IN TWO THOUSAND THREE WE
HAVE THE ROOTED CAL- WE H. BOTH
FTA COULD CONTACT- AS WELL AS
PASSED ASTM. STANDARDS OUR
GROUP DOES STILL COMPOSED
ABILITY. EVERYBODY GET DELIVERY-
WE ALSO UNDER IS BROUGHT UP
EARLIER THERE THAT CAN IMPACT
IN SECTOR. HI THIS TIME OUR
PRODUCTS OF MANUFACTURED BY
WITH THE VARIETY OF TRADITIONAL
PLASTIC COMPANIES. ACROSS
CALIFORNIA DAD- REALLY HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY THE DIFFERENT
REGULATIONS. BTIG THE NEEDS
EMPLOYEES. COULD POTENTIALLY BE
OPEN OR RAMP UP OPERATIONS TO
PRODUCE. AIR CARD OF PRODUCTS
IN THE NEAR FUTURE. WHICH
INCREASED AND IN A GROWING
INDUSTRY EXPERTISE AND
INNOVATIVE AND STABLE PRODUCT
THAT IS TRULY BORN DESIGNED AND
PERFECTED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU THE STATE TO HELP END CLOSE
OF THAT CLASSIC INTO THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND MAKE YOUR MUCH
OF YOUR TIME THIS AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THE MOMENT THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I WILL ASK IF ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY CLOSING
STATEMENTS. MS GARCIA- THANK
YOU TO THE PRESENTER SENT TO
BOTH- THE CHAIR OF NATURAL
RESOURCES IN THE CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE FOR PUTTING
THIS SERIES TOGETHER AS WE TALK
ABOUT POLICY SOLUTIONS AROUND
RECYCLING AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
AROUND REDUCTION OF FOR THE FOR
THE MAN I AM PUTTING MORE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY BACK ON THOSE
OIL PRODUCERS WHO CONTINUE TO
SELL US- THE IDEA THAT WE CAN
RECYCLE OUR WAY OUT OF THIS
PROBLEM. THANK YOU. MISTER YEAH
I THINK YOU- I THANK. YOU KNOW
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT'S NOT AN
EASY ONE BUT- WE CAN'T JUST SIT
HERE AND WAIT FOR. OUR INDUSTRY
PARTNERS AND EVERYBODY ELSE TO
TRY TO COME UP WITH A SOLUTION
THIS IS COME UPON US AND I KNOW
WE OUTLINED SOME OF THE BILLS
WE'VE DONE THE LAST TEN YEARS
AND CERTAINLY THAT'S A START TO
AND- LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING
BACK OUT IN IN IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- BUT I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT MORE AND MORE.
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA I NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THAT HEALTH
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
IMPACTS- FOR ADVOCATE FOR OUR
FOR OUR STATE OUR WELLBEING SO-
THANKS FOR EVERYBODY WHO
PARTICIPATED DAY AND- WE WILL-
CERTAINLY ENGAGE WITH YOU. IN
THE MONTHS AHEAD THANK YOU. I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY UNDER
VERY DIFFICULT. CIRCUMSTANCES
AND CERTAINLY TO THE PANELISTS
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO SHARE.
THEIR KNOWLEDGE AND THEIR
EXPERTISE AND THEIR
EXPERIENCES. UP FOR MY-
PERSPECTIVE IS SOMEONE WHO
COMES OUT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AS WELL AS NO LEGISLATOR I
THINK THE PUBLIC REALLY DOES
NOT UNDERSTAND THE FINANCIAL
AND- TRUE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
OF THIS EXTREMELY DANGEROUS
PRODUCT- BEING PLASTIC. AND WE
HAVE BEEN SOLD A REAL BILL OF
GOODS THAT RECYCLING IS- THE-
SOLUTION AND THAT IF THERE IS
PLASTIC IN THE OCEAN IT'S
BECAUSE OF CONSUMERS OR- OR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE LITTERING.
AND TRULY IT'S- A SYSTEM THAT
JUST WAS NEVER SET UP TO DEAL
WITH WITH. A PRODUCT THAT IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO RECYCLE AND
EXPENSIVE. AND THE SOLUTION IS
TO. TO FIND WAYS OF REDUCING
IT. AND WE HAVE TO DEVELOP THE
POLITICAL WILL. TO DO THAT AND
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE I THINK
THE PUBLIC REALLY UNDERSTANDING
THOSE IMPACTS AND THEY'RE
BEGINNING TO I THINK OUR
CHILDREN UNDERSTAND THE IMPACTS
AT THIS POINT A LOT MORE THAN
THEIR PARENTS DO. AB BUT IT'S
UP TO US TO BE THE PARENTS IN
THE ADULT IN THE ROOM AS WELL.
AND TO BECAUSE MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA SETS THE EXAMPLE OF
WHAT BEING THAT OF WOULD GOOD
STEWARDSHIP IS. SO I HOPE THAT-
WE ALL CAN WORK THIS YEAR.
TOWARDS SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
MEANINGFUL. I KNOW WE HAVE A
LOT OF REALLY COMMITTED AND
VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE MEMBERS- UP
HERE ON THE DYESS AND
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATURE. AND
I. I'VE I FEEL A- VERY HOPEFUL
THAT WE CAN YOU KNOW GET
TOGETHER AND REALLY DO
SOMETHING SO THANKS FOR BEING
HERE TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION
THANKS TO STAFF FOR PUTTING
THIS TOGETHER AND WE'LL SEE YOU
ALL ON WEDNESDAY.